Hey, everybody. This is Walton Gaggins. I'm the guest on Smartless today. And I can't wait to have a conversation with these three fellows. Only one of them know that I'm going to be here. So let's get this conversation started. Thanks for listening. Welcome to Smartless. Smart Less Smart Less Wait, who's guest is it today? Shut up, Sean. Jason's, you can tell by the attitude.
大家好。我是沃尔顿·戈金斯。我是今天《Smartless》节目的嘉宾。我迫不及待地想和这三位老兄聊聊了。他们中只有一个人知道我会来。所以我们开始这场对话吧。感谢收听。欢迎来到《Smartless》。Smart Less Smart Less 等等，今天的嘉宾是谁？闭嘴，肖恩。是杰森的，看这态度就知道了。
Fuck you, piece of shit. Hey, look at Wills on the fucking Western sets. It looks like you have his smoking jacket on. This fucking quilted, self-stitched. What's it called? Santa Fe, something. Yeah. Will, how much research?
操你妈的，你个狗屎。嘿，你看威尔那身西部片造型。看起来你就像穿着他的吸烟夹克。这件该死的绗缝、手工缝制的衣服。叫什么来着？圣达菲什么的。对。威尔，你做了多少功课？
So Will's doing a Western thing. Not a Western. What is it? It's with Michelle Pfeiffer. Yes. He's reprising. By the way, our friend Michelle Fifex
所以威尔在拍西部片。不是西部片。那是什么？是和米歇尔·菲佛合作的。对。他在重演。顺便说一下，我们的朋友米歇尔·菲•
who said to me, it's Mishy Fee. And they said, I said, she goes, I know we've got to take a break so you can do your podcast. She's being sort of coy. She said with a mocking tone.
她对我说，叫我米希·菲。他们说，我说，她说，我知道我们得休息一下，这样你才能去录播客。她表现得有点羞涩。她用嘲讽的语气说。
Yeah. And I said, I said, yeah, She was very good on the show. I said, you were great on the show. We loved having you. And I hope you got good response. And she said that people came out of the woodwork, too, and that people listened to it.
对。然后我说，我说，对。她在剧里的表现非常棒。我说，你在剧里演得太棒了。我们很高兴有你加盟。希望你得到了不错的反响。她说也有很多人慕名而来，而且大家都在听这个节目。
So how about that? That's nice. People always say, I don't want to do the show. And then they're happy that they do the show. That's right. Oh, I don't know. I don't know. Don't you feel like we just all slept together
那感觉怎么样？挺好的。人们总是说，我不想上这个节目。然后他们录完又觉得很高兴。没错。噢，我不知道。我不知道。难道你们不觉得我们好像刚在某个地方的同一个木屋里睡过觉吗？因为我们大约在10个小时前才刚做过这个。我知道。你是说？就像我们刚全都在。好吧，我们说回你。为什么大家都要睡在木屋里？哦，因为我的打扮就像在木屋里一样。
in the same cabin somewhere because we just did this like 10 hours ago? I know. You mean? Like we just all. Well, let's go back to you. Why is everyone sleeping in a cabin? Oh, because I'm dressed like I'm in the cabin.
好吧，不，好吧，我们刚在同一个房子里睡过觉，然后我们刚醒来吃早饭，然后我们又开始录这个了。对。等等，你的梦想是什么？你知道早饭吃什么吗？寿司，我刚说了寿司。才没有。
Well, no, well, that we just all slept in the same house and then we just woke up for breakfast and then we started doing this again. Yeah. Wait, what is your dream? You know what was for breakfast? Sushi, I just said sushi. No, you didn't.
对，我去了扎巴尔斯。你知道扎巴尔斯离得很近。哦，对，以他们的寿司闻名。扎巴尔斯在做寿司。真的。我套上夹克，去了隔壁，吃了一些寿司。我是说，我把它带回家了。我把它带回家了。
Yeah, I went to Zabars. You know, Zabar is really close. Oh, yeah, famous for their sushi. Zabars is making sushi. It's true. I put a jacket on, I went next door, and I ate some sushi. I mean, I brought her home. I brought her home.
嘿，你这个屎猪。还记得昨天你说我刚吃了中餐，我心想，听起来真不错，所以我昨晚给自己点了一些中餐。哦，你点啦？感觉怎么样？我吃了很久以来的第一顿中餐，对吧？好吃吗？没错。你点了什么？我刚才在纳闷你的脸怎么了，因为我能看出有点不对劲，你知道的，威尔——等一下你看看我今天吃完寿司午餐后的脸——对，等等，你点中餐的时候，会点那种，你知道的，比较邪恶的东西吗？比如面包屑炸鸡或面包屑炸什么东西，还是说全是竹笋之类的。
Hey, you shit pig. remember yesterday when you said i just had chinese food i thought to myself self that sounds really good and so i ordered some chinese for me last night oh you did how about that i had chinese for the first time in a long time right was it good that's right what did you have i was wondering about your face because i i could see there was something you know will um wait till you see my face after uh sushi lunch today yeah wait do you get um do you get like you know anything kind of naughty When you order Chinese, like breaded chicken or breaded something or is it all like a bamboo shoots and, you know.
没有，我，我们点了几个鸡肉菜和一道面条，还有一些蔬菜。对，你得这么点。因为我对阿曼达说，我说，你点宝贝。我不想，别让我看到菜单上的任何东西，因为我会点，我会点肖恩的菜。她完全点得很清淡，什么都很好。对，而且很好吃。
No, I, we had a couple of chicken dishes and a noodle dish and there's some vegetables. Yeah, you got to do it. You know, because I said to Amanda, I said, you order baby. I don't want to, don't let me see anything on the menu because I'll order, I'll order Sean's food. And she went like totally clean and everything right. Yeah, and it was good.
而且太棒了。好吧，等等，威尔，我这辈子见过的最恶心的画面之一，就是去杰森家，他在后院的泳池里游泳，而阿曼达戴着一顶大帽子遮阳。
And it was great. All right, wait, Will, one of the grossest, images I ever witnessed in my life was going over to Jason's house and he's swimming in his pool in the backyard while Amanda has a big hat on covering the sun
他从泳池里的浮排上喊道：“亲爱的，我们午饭能吃点寿司吗？”当时他正顶着太阳烤着，这太好莱坞式的恶心了。他用FaceTime打来的，他在泳池的浮排上漂着。我当时就想，而且我当时
and from the pool on his floaty he goes honey can we get some sushi for lunch while he's baking in the sun it's so Hollywood gross he facetime he went floating on a floaty in his pool I was like at and I was just
满脑子想的都是欧内斯特·博格宁在泳池里的样子，因为他会——顺便说一下，顺便说一下，顺便说一下，它让我想起了一件事，我差点忘了告诉你——不久前，我遇到了格里芬·邓恩，我们的老朋友格里芬·邓恩，伟大的格里芬·邓恩，伟大的格里芬·邓恩。所以，格里芬·邓恩，他说，我一直想看，我一直想把这个故事告诉你，我一直想把这个故事告诉你，他说多年前——这是公开记录——
all I thought about was like obviously Ernest Borg9 in the pool because he would be by the way by the way by the way by the way it just reminded me I forgot to tell you so a little while ago I run into Griffin done our old pal Griffin done the great Griffin done the great Griffin done so so Griffin done so he says I've been meaning to see I've been meaning to tell you this story been meaning to tell you the story he said years ago when this is public record
他说，当欧内斯特·博格宁在离婚时，他的妻子在法庭记录中列出的其中一个问题，她发现这个问题是离婚的理由，
he said when Ernest Borgnine was getting divorced his wife cited one of the problems that she cited in the court record was of their differences that she found that as a problem as grounds for divorce
就是欧内斯特·博格宁会用“荷兰烤箱”熏她——他会在床上放屁，然后把被子拉过她的头顶。这是真的吗？这是真的吗？发誓这是真的，我查过了，千真万确。她恨透了，觉得恶心透了。所以他当时想，我得告诉威尔，我得给他打电话。
was that Ernest Borgnine would Dutch oven her he'd fart in the bed and pull the covers over her head Is that real? Is that real? Swear to God it's apparently and I looked it up, it's true. And she hated it, and she was disgusted by it. And so he was like, I got to tell, Will, I got to call him.
所以他有我以前的电话号码，因为我已经有四年左右没跟他说过话了，而且我换了号码。所以他一直在给我发信息。他给我打电话，那家伙接起来说：“喂？”他说：“嘿，听着，你知道，关于格里芬的事……”他接着说：“嘿，威尔。”那家伙说，有点支支吾吾地说：“对。”然后他说：“听着，关于欧内斯特·博格宁的事，还有他离婚的原因，以及那个‘荷兰烤箱’……”
So he had my old phone number, because I haven't spoken to him in like four years or something, and I switched my number. So he keeps, he's sending me stuff. And he calls me, and the guy goes, hello? And he goes, hey, listen, now, you know, this thing about Griff, you know, he goes, hey, well, and the guy says, sort of says, yeah. And then he goes, listen, Ernest Borgnein, and the thing, and the reason he got divorced, and the Dutch,
……这档子事。那家伙说：“这不是威尔。好吧，他换号码了。”就是这样。太恶心了。你为什么会觉得我想知道这种恶心事？然后就把我电话挂了。天哪，太搞笑了。作为背景故事，我的听众应该知道，我多年前买下了欧内斯特·博格宁的老房子，多年前买的。而且威尔多年来一直写信给我，说我做了一笔糟糕的交易，因为——这不是一笔糟糕的交易，威尔——考虑到据说欧内斯特·博格宁是个世界级的自慰高手。好吧，他把自己的长寿归功于他声称自己每天都自慰。所以我一直想象他在屋里的各个地方靠着栏杆……
chubbing this stuff and the guy goes this isn't well okay he's changed his number and that is it disgusting why would you think i'd want to know this disgusting and hung up on my god that's really funny uh my listener as a backstory you should know that um i bought ernest borgnine's old house years ago years ago and uh will has been writing me for years that what i've done is i've made a bad purchase because not a bad purchase well when you consider consider that supposedly Ernest Borgneem was a world-class masturbator. Well, he credited his longevity with the fact that he claimed that he masturbated every day. So I've always imagined him everywhere in the house leading against the rail.
我不知道为什么这是个好木屋。对。而且它也在泳池里，威尔，主卧里还滞留着大量的屁。好吧。明白了。对，当欧内斯特·博格宁……不，不。太疯狂了。欢迎来到《SmartLus》。
I don't know why it's a good shack. Yeah. And so it's in the pool too, Will, and there's also lots of farts stuck in the master. Okay. Got it. Yeah, and when Ernest Borgonite, no, no. That is crazy. Welcome to SmartLus.
所以我一直想告诉你这件事。好了，让我翻翻我的笔记。哦，对。很有条理。好吧。我写了一小段开场白。在哪儿呢？来了。
So I've been meaning to tell you that. All right, let me pull up my notes here. Oh, yeah. It's organized. All right. I've written a little intro. Where is it? Here it comes.
我们今天有这些。真流畅。哦，天哪。别大喊大叫了。好吧，我们广告回来了。我们今天请到的是一位演员，一位令人兴奋的演员。这家伙懂得如何把你背在背上，
What we've got here today. So smooth. Oh, God. Stop shouting. Well, we're back from commercial. What we've got here today is an actor, an exciting actor. this guy knows how to put you on his back
把你带进一些相当有趣角色的世界里。有些搞笑，有些吓人，有些黑暗，有些轻松。不管怎样，这总是一段美妙的旅程。他那种演员，能让你露出期待的微笑，并感到一种宽慰，觉得无论你要去哪里，你都掌握在稳妥的手中。
and carry you into the world of some pretty interesting characters. Some are funny, some are scary, some are dark, some are breezy. Whatever it is, though, it's always a good ride. He's the kind of actor that gives you the grin of expectation and the feeling of relief that you're in good hands for wherever you're going.
伙计们，这些都是我自己写的。他出生在阿拉巴马州，在佐治亚州长大，19岁搬到好莱坞，在电影中为我们带来了标志性的角色，比如《被解救的姜戈》、《八恶人》，而在电视上，他在《盾牌》等剧集中为我们奉献了黄金表演，
Guys, I write these myself. He was born in Alabama, raised in Georgia, moved to Hollywood at 19, and has brought us iconic roles in films like, Django Unchained The hateful 8 and on TV's given us gold in shows like the shield
还有《火线警探》、《副校长》、《右派 gemstones》（译注：实际应为《山根宝石》）、最近的《白莲花》和《辐射》。伙计们，这位是沃尔顿·戈金斯。嘿，伙计，他来了，我们开始吧。
justified vice principles righteous gemstones and recently white lotus and fallout dudes here's Mr. Walton Goggins Jr. Yo man here he is now we get it started
我不知道你必须每天自慰才能演好《麦克海海军》呢。如果你想长久混下去，你得把体内的邪气排出去。该死，我还想演那部剧呢。你今天怎么看起来这么精神？
I didn't know that you had to masturbate every day to lead McHale's Navy you got to get the evil out if you want to stick around a while damn it I wanted to get that show. Why do you look so sharp today?
我看起来精神吗？他正处于宣传期中间。对，在中间。第三天还是第四天来着，差不多吧。对，真的，伙计。但这今天是第一场。所以我喝了一杯卡布奇诺，所以状态还行。对，你得保持清醒。
Do I look sharp? He's in the middle of a junket. Yeah, in the middle. Day, day, I think, three or four, something like that. Yeah, really, man. But this is the first one for today. So I had a cappuccino, so I'm doing okay. Yeah, you got to be fresh.
这是为《辐射》宣传吗？对，为了《辐射》。对，这是《辐射》。对，对。我知道，你知道，有神秘嘉宾，我前几天还见到威尔了。我知道。你嘴巴闭得挺严吧？
This is for fallout? Yeah, for fallout. Yeah, this is fallout. Yeah, yeah. And I knew, you know, I know that there's a surprise guest, and I saw Will the other night. I know. Did you keep it zipped?
你演得太棒了。好吧，我不知道是谁，我不知道是谁邀请了我。老兄，你演得太棒了，我完全不知道。我是说，我的注意力全集中在你穿的那件长款皮大衣上了，那房间里可是有100华氏度（约38摄氏度）。我也是，因为我在流汗。那天晚上我瘦了10磅。太棒了。
You were so good. Well, I didn't know who was, I didn't know who, like, invited me. Dude, you were so good, I had no idea. I mean, I was focused on your full-length leather coat you were wearing, and it was 100 degrees in that room. So was I, because I was sweating. I lost 10 pounds that night. It's great.
天哪。嘿，所以情况是这样的，MGT。也许我们已经嗅出了，有时候沃尔顿，偶尔会有嘉宾走到我们三个中间的一个人面前，
Oh, my God. Hey, so here's the deal, MGT. Maybe we've just sniffed out what the, maybe the hole is sometimes when every once in a while, Walton, a guest will come up to one of the three of us. and say, hey, can't wait to see you next week. Or the rep. Or the rep or something like that.
然后说：“嘿，迫不及待地想看你下周的节目。”或者经纪人。或者经纪人什么的。
So what I think is the guest needs to be told, Michael, who the hosting fella is. They're told. The rest are told. They are told. We're keeping that in. We're keeping that they're told in. The host, I mean, the guest knows who the hosts are.
所以我觉得应该告诉嘉宾，迈克尔，主持的家伙是谁。他们被告知了。其他人被告知了。他们被告知了。我们会把这段剪进去。我们会把“他们被告知了”这段剪进去。主持人，我是说，嘉宾知道主持是谁。
This is smartless, man. No, no, but you didn't know. Your people didn't tell you. Yes. Yes, that's right. You know who we need to be speaking to are Walton's representatives. They get them on the phone. Yeah, we're going to get some of them are in the room right now.
这是《Smartless》，老兄。不，不，但你当时不知道。你的人没告诉你。对。对，没错。我们需要找人谈谈，那就是沃尔顿的经纪团队。把他们叫来。对，我们现在房间里就有几个人。
Do you hear that? Why didn't you tell me, honestly? It doesn't matter. It's truly just to cut down on homework for the other two. What's up, fellas? What's up, bud? It's so good to meet you. So you're out there with the sandwich board for Fallout.
你听到了吗？老实说，你为什么不告诉我？没关系。其实就是为了减少另外两个人的家庭作业。最近怎么样，伙计们？最近怎么样，兄弟？很高兴见到你。所以你现在正为《辐射》到处宣传呢。
I am. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. We're just starting. And how are, let's just jump off right there. How are you enjoying? God, he loves to jump off. What's the pre-call? I love to jump off.
是的。对，对，对，对。我们才刚开始。那么，让我们直接切入正题吧。你觉得怎么样？天哪，他最喜欢切入正题了。前的通告是什么？我最喜欢切入正题了。
What's the pre-call on that? You got a two-hour pre-call there for the makeup chair? Yeah, man. It's like three hours, you know, before anybody else shows up. I mean, it got so bad, like, not so bad, but we were, we filmed the first season in New York. Yeah. For some reason, honestly. Well, because you've got a place there, a beautiful place there in the Hudson Valley.
那个前的通告是怎么安排的？化妆椅那边得提前两个小时做准备吗？对，老兄。差不多提前三 hours，你知道的，在其他人出现之前。我是说，情况变得很糟糕，也不是很糟糕，但我们在纽约拍了第一季。对。不知何故，说实话。好吧，因为你在那里有个地方，在哈德逊河谷有个漂亮的地方。
They thought maybe we'll make it geographically. attractive for Mr. Guggins. But never saw it. I never left the city, really, except to go to Namibia. But we're out here now, and we were out filming in the desert. I've got this van, you know,
他们以为也许我们在地理位置上能吸引戈金斯先生。但我从没见过。我基本上没离开过市里，除了去纳米比亚。但我们现在来到这儿了，我们之前在沙漠里拍戏。我有一辆面包车，你知道的，
that like so many other people. That you rent back to the company and you call it your dressing room? As a matter of fact, I do. Wait, what? It's working. Yeah, here's what you do, Sean. What are you talking about?
就像其他很多人一样……你把它租回给公司，然后管它叫你的化妆间？事实上，我确实这么做了。等等，什么？这行得通。对，肖恩，你是这么操作的：你在说什么？
When you're a fancy pants like Walton and you're working all the time, the smart money is spent on like a motor home or a van or something like that. You buy it yourself. Yeah, and then you rent it back to the production as your dressing room. And so they give you the money for dressing room rental.
当你像沃尔顿这样是个大牌，而且一直在工作时，明智的做法是花钱买一辆房车或面包车之类的大件。你自己买。对，然后你把它租回给剧组当你的化妆间。所以他们会付给你化妆间租金。
It's all pays for itself. It pays for itself. Kind of. Yeah, I mean, it's a little harder in New York than it is in Los Angeles. Parking on 8th Avenue. Yeah, parking is very expensive there. Parking tickets offset the rental fee. Yeah, but it did.
这基本上能自给自足。它能自给自足。某种程度上。对，我是说，在纽约比在洛杉矶难一点。把车停在第八大道上。对，那里的停车费非常贵。停车罚单抵消了租金。对，但确实如此。
It worked out, you know. It worked out. But so we got to a point where we were kind of filming like out in the desert a few times. And then I just stayed for the first time, I don't know if you guys have ever done this, but I stayed at base camp. You slept in your trailer overnight?
结果还不错，你知道。结果还不错。但后来我们到了那种在沙漠里拍了几次戏的地步。然后我第一次留下来，我不知道你们有没有做过这种事，但我留在了大本营。你晚上睡在拖车里？
You know, really kind of bad hotel rooms, like in the middle of nowhere. You slept at the location. Yeah, at the location with a security guard. Everybody else leaves. And I just had my food. Did you stick them for the hotel money too? Give me that?
你知道的，那种条件很差的酒店房间，在鸟不生蛋的地方。你直接睡在片场。对，就睡在片场，只有一个保安。其他人全走了。我只带着我的食物。你连酒店的钱也敲诈了他们一份？把那个给我？
Yeah, I got those $60. Yeah, I said, no, come on. I love it. Let me have that chair. And you have your shower and a little kitchen in there and everything. Yeah, everything. And it was only $60.
对，我拿了那60美元。对，我说，不，行了吧。我喜欢。把那把椅子给我。而且你在里面有淋浴间、小厨房和一切设施。对，应有尽有。而且只要60美元。
four steps to work. You didn't shower there. I mean, I had, yeah, I did shower there. Did you? Yeah, as a matter of every single night. Yeah, of course. I mean, you got to shower when you had that stuff on your face.
离工作地点只有四步路。你可没在那里洗澡。我是说，我有，对，我在那儿洗过澡。真的吗？对，事实上每天晚上都洗。对，当然。我是说，你脸上有那些东西，你必须洗澡。
Jason would never use that water. You'd never use trailer water, right? Yeah, no, exactly. I don't want to smell like a hose. I have filtered. I only use. But, Walt, you do strike me as a fella, you do strike me as a fella that is not
杰森才永远不会用那种水。你绝不会用拖车里的水，对吧？对，没错。我可不想闻起来像根水管。我有过滤水。我只用。但是，沃尔顿，你确实给我一种这样的感觉，你给我的感觉是一个不怕光脚踩在酒店地毯上的家伙。
afraid to walk barefoot on a hotel rug. No, no, I'll walk barefoot across a desert. Exactly. You're a guy that you're much, you're not, I'm a soft, I'm a soft man. You don't seem like a soft fella at all. You can handle quite a bit of, you know, taking away the creature comforts. You know, well, I just, I had an experience where all the creature comforts were taken away. Like, and I didn't realize how, how many they were going to take away. But I took my, I'm a father. Sure.
不，不，我敢光脚走过沙漠。没错。你是个随遇而安的人，你不是——我是个娇生惯养的人。你看起来一点也不娇生惯养。你能忍受相当多的、你知道的，失去物质上的舒适。你知道，我经历过一次，所有的物质舒适都被剥夺了。就像，我没意识到他们会剥夺那么多。但我带了我的——我是一个父亲。当然。
To two of the parents here and Sean, you have a dog. I know that's, yeah. You know, I just have one, so I can kind of, you know, not take a job for a while. But I took him, he was 14, right, about a turn 15. And it's like, okay, well, we, you know, this is a big transition kind of in your life, and we need to mark this occasion. And I took him on a two-week horseback riding trip across Western Mongolia. Oh, wow.
在场的两位也是父亲，肖恩，你有一只狗。我知道，对，没错。你知道，我只有一个孩子，所以我可以，你知道的，一段时间不接工作。但我带他去了，他当时14岁，快15岁了。这就像是，好吧，你知道，这是你生命中的一个重大转折点，我们需要纪念这个时刻。我带他去进行了为期两周的蒙古西部骑马旅行。哦，哇。
Yeah, no, it's a big deal. It was a big deal. He's 14. He'll be 15 in about six weeks. and it was just an opportunity for us to kind of get out there and see the world and we're both obsessed with Genghis Khan Jason would be stressed
对，不，这是一件大事。这绝对是一件大事。他14岁。再过六周左右他就15岁了。这只是一个让我们去那里看看世界的机会，而且我们俩都迷恋成吉思汗。杰森肯定会压力山大的。
going to the first class lounge in Mongolia like that would be actually where are you going to find a TV with CNN International or coffee pods or anything like that when you're a signal man but where do you again you do strike me as a guy who's so
去蒙古那种地方坐头等舱休息室，实际上当你是信号兵的时候，你在哪儿能找到一台有CNN国际频道的电视、咖啡胶囊或者类似的东西呢？但话说回来，你给我的感觉确实是一个
sort of there's a lot of texture in your life I'm like I'm surrounded with thread count and things like that I like well I like thread count too you know but you know how to do both Mongolian Kashmir
生活很有质感的人，我好像周围全是高支纱床单之类的东西。我说，其实我也喜欢高支纱床单，你知道的，但你又懂怎么去过那种蒙古羊绒般的粗野生活。
I mean I like all of those things but on this trip here's what here's what happened and other than maybe we'll get to like a parenting moment you know with my son which was extraordinary but on day three I mean it took us
我是说，我喜欢所有这些东西，但这次旅行是这样的——除了也许我们会讲到一个育儿时刻，你知道的，和我儿子的，那是非凡的——但在第三天，我是说我们花了
it took us about like 72 hours just to get to the starting point, you know, and stopped and missed a flight, spent the night in Istanbul, which is, you know, hey, throw me in the briar patches. I loved that place. And we made it to Alam Batar, then another plane landed in Western Mongolia, and then like an eight-hour drive to just the starting point. We got there, and it was just the two of us. We're obsessed with that part of the world, and then we start, you know, we meet everybody.
我们花了大约72小时才到达起点，你知道的，中间停下来还错过了航班，在伊斯坦布尔过夜，而这，你知道的，嘿，把我扔进荆棘丛吧，我爱那个地方。我们到了乌兰巴托，然后坐另一架飞机降落在西蒙古，接着又开了大约八个小时的车才到起点。我们到了那儿，就只有我们俩。我们对世界的那个角落着迷，然后我们开始，你知道的，我们见到了所有人。
Nobody speaks English. We have an interpreter. It's just the two of us, five horses, I mean, seven horses, five camels. And an interpreter, two horsemen, an eagle hunter. Who sets this up? And a cook, man. Like, it's legit. It's the real deal.
没人会说英语。我们有个翻译。就我们俩，五匹马，我是说，七匹马，五头骆驼。还有一个翻译，两个马夫，一个鹰猎人。谁安排的这一切？还有一个厨师，伙计。真的，是来真的。
Wow. And we're both, like, in the tent, the first night looking at each other going, like, we're here, man. We did that. We did it. And the very first, when we landed in Western Mongolia, my son looked at me, and he said, I've never been this happy in my life, Dad. So he's got that wanderlust like I do. So cut to day two, you know, something like that kind of happened. And he, you know, was like, wow, this is, excuse my language, this is really fucking hard, dad.
哇。我们俩第一天晚上在帐篷里看着对方说，伙计，我们到了。我们做到了。我们真的做到了。而且就在刚落地西蒙古的时候，我儿子看着我，他说，爸，我这辈子从没这么快乐过。所以他跟我一样，有着那种对远方的渴望。镜头一转到第二天，你知道的，类似的事情发生了。他，你知道的，就觉得，哇，请原谅我说粗话，爸，这真的他妈的太难了。
Like, this is really hard. Like, this is really hard. And he was, you know, he was missing his mom and missing, you know, his life. And I said, you know what, buddy, I understand it is hard. You're absolutely right about it. It's very, very hard. And you can be in this place and I'll hold you and I'll love you. and I'll comfort you in this time.
就像，这真的很难。就像，这真的很难。然后他，你知道的，他想妈妈了，也想，你知道的，他原来的生活。我说，你知道吗，伙计，我理解这确实很难。你说得完全对。这非常非常难。你可以在这个地方，我会抱着你，我会爱你的，
Or you can, he said he really wanted to go home. And I said, okay, but I'll hold you and I'll comfort you. And for as long as you want, I mean, for the next 12 days. Or you can accept that this is your reality, right? You're not changing this reality. And you can let that fester and you can react to that. Or you can accept the fact that this is your reality and actually learn and not waste that energy.
我会在这段时期安慰你。或者你可以——他说他真的很想回家。我说，好吧，我会抱着你，我会安慰你的，只要你想要，我是说，接下来的12天都行。或者你可以接受这就是你的现实，对吧？你无法改变这个现实。你可以让这种情绪溃烂，然后对此做出反应。或者你可以接受这就是你的现实，并真正去学习，不要浪费那份精力。
Just touch the most emotion. It's up to you. And literally, at 14 years old, you see, I just need, can I use the battery? Because there's no, you don't have cell phones. We only have, you know, a little bitty batteries with us or whatever. It's like, you can use the battery if you use it up, use it, whatever you want. He's like, I just need to listen to some music. Yeah.
触动最深的情感。这取决于你。真的，在14岁的时候，你看，我只需要——我能用一下电池吗？因为没有，你们没有手机。我们随身只有，你知道的，一点点小的电池或者别的什么。就像，电池你可以用，用光了就用，随你便。他就像，我只是需要听点音乐。好吧。
He did. He sat in the tent. He came out about 45 minutes later. And he just looked up at me. with this big, beautiful grin on his face. With a plane ticket. No, I'm kidding. Yeah, with a plane.
他照做了。他在帐篷里坐着。大约45分钟后他出来了。他只是抬头看着我，
And he thumbs up. Like, I'm good, Dad, I'm good. And then, so it's like, okay, he got through that. The next morning, I'm on the horse. We're all leaving, this whole caravan. It takes the whole process of getting ready to go. And I've been riding horses my whole life. My son is an unbelievable rider.
脸上带着灿烂、美好的笑容。拿着一张机票。不，开玩笑的。对，拿着一张机票。然后竖起大拇指。就像，我没事，爸，我很好。然后，好吧，他挺过去了。第二天早上，我骑在马上。我们所有人都要出发了，整个商队。准备出发的过程挺繁琐的。我一辈子都在骑马。我儿子是个极出色的骑手。
And my horse just trips. Uh-oh. And I went down. I didn't see any. I didn't see it coming. Oh, now who's got to go home? Yeah, well, she rolled on top of me. Exactly.
然后我的马突然绊了一下。噢哦。然后我摔下去了。我根本没看见。我一点都没预料到。哦，现在是谁得回家了？对啊，嗯，它翻身压在我身上。没错。
Well, this is what happened. She rolled on top of me. And I was able to push her off thinking like, oh, my God, I just broke my leg. That's it. And looked down, it was like, okay, legs fine. Everything's okay. And then I went to stand up, and I immediately collapsed. Something was wrong.
嗯，事情是这样的。它翻身压在我身上。我把它推开，心想，天哪，我的肋骨断了。完了。低头一看，心想，好吧，腿没事。一切都好。然后我试着站起来，接着我马上就瘫倒了。有哪里不对劲。
Something was really wrong. And my son looked at me. He was like, Dad, are you okay? I was like, yeah, dude, I'm okay. All right. I got up on the horse. rode for seven hours don't remember it
有哪里非常不对劲。我儿子看着我。他问，爸，你没事吧？我说，没事，伙计，我没事。好吧。我重新跨上马，
had a couple of Advil my wife threw in a bag what I realized you know after a few days is that I broke my riff oh God and then all of a sudden I'm like taking the advice
骑了七个小时，完全不记得怎么过来的了。吃了两片我老婆塞在包里的止痛片。我意识到，你知道的，几天后我发现我断了一根肋骨。哦天哪。然后突然之间，我开始听从
that I just gave my son because it's like hey man nobody's coming to get you you know in the middle of nowhere there is no like helicopter coming to air vacuum out of here man meta vacue out of here you got to go you got to ride
我刚刚给儿子提的建议，因为就像，嘿，伙计，没有人会来接你的，你知道的，在荒郊野岭，没有什么直升机来把空运救走，老兄，从这儿医疗撤离。你得走，你得骑马。
and so it was you know another nine days. Where is that kind of... That is... Dude, dude, Jay, are you going to tell the story about... Do I have to cred now? Jay, you're about when the guy didn't have your valet ticket at the Governor's Awards?
所以，你知道的，又是九天。那种……那真是……伙计，伙计，杰伊，你打算讲那个关于……我现在有资格装酷了吗？杰伊，就是那个在州长奖上找不到代客泊车小票的家伙？
Yeah, and I'm like, hey, man. You waited like 10 minutes for them to sort out your limo. You remember that? A solid 10 minutes. This happened two days ago. I had to talk to a bunch of people I didn't want to talk to. My tucks was sort of itchy. And we offered to hold them.
对啊，然后我就想，嘿，伙计。你等了大概10分钟让他们帮你把豪华轿车开过来。你还记得吗？整整10分钟。这事就发生在两天前。我不得不跟一堆我根本不想说话的人聊天。我的礼服领结有点扎人。我们主动提出帮他们拿着。
Well, and where did you get this kind of, this kind of thick skin emotionally, spiritually? Did you have a couple of good parents? Well, I mean, I think we all have thick skin. You know, it's just a matter of being exposed to it. Look, I'm a poor kid from Georgia, and my parents were divorced when I was three years old. Yeah. And I grew up around a bunch of, you know, when I say crazy. You say it with love.
嗯，那你这种，这种厚脸皮，在情感上、精神上是从哪儿来的？你有两位好父母吗？好吧，我的意思是，我想我们都有厚脸皮。你知道的，这只是接触多了的事。听着，我是佐治亚州来的穷孩子，我三岁时父母就离异了。对。我是在一群，你知道的——当我说是疯子的时候。你是带着爱意说的。
With love. Yeah, yeah, curious and. really colorful, colorful southern women, you know, and a little bitty farmhouse, you know, outside of Atlanta. And, yeah, we didn't have, we didn't have anything. We didn't have, like, you know, central air. I mean, we had like a heater, you know, that emitted, I mean, like, it is the cause of global warming, like this one particular furnace that we had in our, in our house. And, yeah, we just didn't have much. And so, but we didn't, we didn't want, much and i don't know i just think growing up that way then what about all this all this privilege
带着爱意。对，对，好奇且。非常有个性、有个性的南方女人，你知道的，在亚特兰大郊外的一栋小农舍里，你知道的。而且，是的，我们没有，我们什么都没有。我们没有，就像，你知道的，中央空调。我的意思是，我们有一个取暖器，你知道的，它散发出的热量——我的意思是，简直是全球变暖的罪魁祸首，就像我们家里那个特定的火炉。所以，是的，我们确实没多少东西。因此，但我们也不，不奢求什么，我不知道，我只是觉得以那种方式长大，那关于所有这些特权
and luxury and i love it elitism that you're rolling around with every once in a while you think is it getting you soft i love it yeah no uh do i do i do it's it getting me soft yeah i mean i suppose yeah right you get you everybody has a new normal but you know how to categorize it right yeah i think so yeah yeah you're still able to go to mongoli and get along absolutely yeah can i ask you some questions about that story that it's crazy I just can't leave I'm talking to three of you man
和奢华，我喜欢它，还有你偶尔会沾染上的精英主义，你觉得这会让你变得娇惯吗？我喜欢它。对，没有，呃，我会吗？我会吗？这会让我变得娇惯吗？对，我是说，我想是的，对吧？你习惯了，每个人都有了新的常态，但你知道怎么给它归类，对吧？对，我想是的，对吧。你依然能去蒙古并且融入那里。绝对的，对。我能问你一些关于那个故事的问题吗？太疯狂了，我简直离不开，我在跟你们三个人聊天，伙计。
this is just so because two of you I know and Sean I don't know so yes ask me anything We went to Sean I went to Istanbul once Yeah we went to Istanbul Don't make that together
这实在是，因为你们俩我都认识，肖恩我不认识，所以，是的，随便问我什么。我们去过，肖恩和我去过一次伊斯坦布尔。对，我们去过伊斯坦布尔。别把那事扯在一起。
Yeah They were at the four seasons They're at the old prison That's true That is true But By you remember Like a week
对。他们当时在四季酒店。他们就在那座老监狱里。是真的。确实如此。但是，你还记得吗，大概一个星期。
A week after we left It was like a big terrorist attack You remember that? I know Like a week after we got out of it Wow we'll be right back and now back to the show
在我们离开后一个星期。就像发生了一场大的恐怖袭击。你记得吗？我知道。就像我们刚离开那里一个星期。哇，我们马上回来，现在回到节目中。
um so the the broken rib how do you get through that many days this is going to be about ribs at chin chin okay well it's really interesting you talk about no how do I get through with a broken rib yeah I get you through that many nine days what do you do with the pain and how do you heal and like what do you do
嗯，所以那个断了的肋骨，你是怎么熬过那么多天的？这难道是要在金金餐厅聊肋骨吗？好吧，这真的很有趣，你谈到，不，我是怎么带着断肋骨熬过来的？对，你是怎么熬过那漫长的九天的？你该怎么对付疼痛，怎么疗伤，还有你都做了什么？
okay he's hard man he can do it well no I mean like But there's no, I didn't know what was happening, right? I didn't, and it did, you know, I got to be honest with you, man. I felt like, oh, you know, maybe this is internal bleeding. Maybe this is it. Like, I was really, I was scared, but I tried not to show that to my son. And I said when we got to this particular, the next location after that seven-hour ride. And I crawled into this tent.
好吧，他很硬气，伙计，他能做到。不，我是说，但没有，我当时不知道发生了什么，对吧？我不知道，而且确实，你知道的，老实说，伙计。我觉得，哦，你知道的，也许这是内出血。也许就是这样。就像，我真的很，我很害怕，但我尽量不把这展现给我儿子。我当时说，当我们到达那个特定地点——那七个小时的骑马行程之后的下一站。我爬进了这个帐篷。
I mean, they took me off this horse, which, by the way, I had the only horse in, uh, Mongolia, um, with, uh, Alzheimer's, man. Like, she, she had no idea who I was. It's like, man, I've been writing you for eight hours a day, man. I didn't stop for lunch. I'll only been gone for 20 minutes, man. Like, I'm here. Like, there's not a, I don't have a scent.
我是说，他们把我从马上扶下来，顺便说一句，我在蒙古骑的是唯一一匹有阿尔茨海默病的马，伙计。就像，她根本不知道我是谁。就像，伙计，我一天骑你八个小时，伙计。我连午饭都没停。我不过才离开20分钟，伙计。我在这儿。就像，没有，我身上没有气味。
I mean, really? Right, right. But, no, I crawled into this tent and I looked at my son and I said, listen, man, I'm going to take this ad, bill, and we're going to see if I wake up with, uh, any relief. And, uh, and if it is, then I think, you know, we're going to be over. okay, everything's fine. And I did, I fell asleep, I don't even remember falling asleep. I woke up, I don't know, three hours later or something like that.
我是说，真的吗？对，对。但是，没有，我爬进这个帐篷，看着我儿子说，听着，伙计，我要吃这个止痛片，然后我们看看我醒来时会不会稍微好受一点。然后，如果是那样的话，我想，你知道的，我们就熬过去了。好吧，一切都好。然后我照做了，我睡着了，我甚至不记得自己是什么时候睡着的。我醒来时，不知道，大概三个小时后吧。
And I felt marginally better, right? Because I'd found a place that wasn't so painful, Sean. Right, thank you. And then I was able to make it out of the tent. I walked in. I mean, I'm in Mongolia. It's the best horse people in the world. You know, they had an idea of kind of what it was.
我觉得稍微好一点了，肖恩，因为我找到了一个没那么痛的姿势。对，谢谢。然后我勉强爬出了帐篷。我走了进去。我是说，我在蒙古。那里有世界上最棒的马术民族。你知道的，他们大概知道这是怎么回事。
And then while I was sleeping, they fermented a bunch of yak vodka. sure you know like yak milk and so I I just I drank we killed a goat that day and and I drank this yak vodka they just when we left there for the next thing they we had these like two gallons of yak vodka so I would just like in the morning you know like with coffee and follow it with a shot of yak vodka and a little bit ad bill you can't get that at the marriott now just a mouthful of goat yeah exactly and it was and we had no refrigeration for that goat, but we ate that goat every way one can eat a goat. Oh, I can't think of anything I'd rather not do.
然后在我睡觉的时候，他们发酵了一大堆牦牛伏特加。当然，你知道的，就像牦牛奶之类的，所以我，我直接喝了。那天我们宰了一只山羊，我喝了那种牦牛伏特加。等我们离开那里去下一个地方时，我们带了大约两加仑这种牦牛伏特加。所以我早上就会，你知道的，喝着咖啡，然后来上一小口牦牛伏特加，再吃一点止痛片。你在万豪酒店可喝不到这个。现在，只要来上一大口山羊肉，对，就是这样。而且，我们没有给那只山羊冷藏，但我们把那只山羊能做成的一切吃法都吃遍了。哦，我想不出还有什么是我更不愿意去做的。
Just watching Jason's face. Really? Because I'm going to invite all of you on the next trip. I would have an uncomfortable time just researching that trip. You know what? Okay, this is reading about it. The websites I'd have to go to to research this would have a font and a sort of a user interface that would be,
光是看着杰森的表情。真的吗？因为我打算邀请你们所有人参加下一次旅行。光是做那次旅行的调研，我就会觉得很不舒服。你知道吗？好吧，看这些。为了做调研我不得不访问的那些网站，它们的字体和用户界面会是
aesthetically unappealing to me and let alone go to the country. What's wrong with me? Because my son was, you know, at this age, I said, and he's obsessed. I got a smart kid, y'all. Like he's a very, very, very bright, very curious man. I can't even say young man
在美学上让我无法接受，更别提去那个国家了。我怎么了？因为我儿子当时，你知道的，在这个年纪，我说，而且他很痴迷。我有个聪明的孩子，各位。他是个非常、非常、非常聪慧、非常好奇的人。我甚至不能称他为年轻人，
because if you sit with him, you feel like you're talking to somebody's been in a mom. How old is he now, well? He's still 14, man. Like he turns, he's a New Year's Day, baby. So this was a recent, Oh, man, I just got back like two months ago, man. Well, how's your rip now?
因为如果你和他坐在一起，你会觉得你是在和一个在妈……他现在多大了，沃尔特？他还是个14岁的孩子，伙计。他属於，他是元旦出生的宝宝。所以这是最近的事，哦，天哪，我大概两个月前才刚回来，伙计。那你的肋骨现在怎么样了？
You know, better. I mean, I got, I got, I mean, look, it was, it's such a long story, but it kind of made it, like, kept going, and day three, it took me, that's when it, like, got really bad. And it took me, like, an hour and a half just to get out of the tent. I'd wake up before my kid did just so that he didn't see me that way. So you'd go do this trip again. Oh, yeah. Oh, one hundred one, with you guys.
你知道的，好多了。我是说，我有，我有——听着，这话说来话长，但它差不多就这样，一直在坚持。到了第三天，花了我，那就是情况变得很糟的时候。我花了大概一个半小时才爬出帐篷。我会在我孩子醒来之前就醒来，这样他就不会看到我那副样子。所以你还会再去进行这种旅行吗？哦，会。哦，百分之一百，跟你们一起。
No. The war of us. You won't find me that. I'll drive you to the airport. That's it. What about like a safari in Africa? What's okay. Look, what's the most adventurous experience that you've ever given yourself?
不。我们可不干。你在那儿找不到我。我顶多送你去机场。这就行了。那比如去非洲进行一次野生动物游猎呢？什么叫可以。听着，你给过自己最具有冒险精神的体验是什么？
Go ahead. Yeah. Well, during COVID, like right before COVID hit, I booked a Scotty thing where we were going to go on the Orient Express. It's like his dream to go on that train across Europe. And so that's like the most extravagant thing I would have ever done. But that's on a fancy train. wind up you didn't you know because have you ever done anything out in nature though
说吧。好吧，在新冠疫情期间，就在疫情爆发前不久，我预订了一次苏格兰的行程，我们要去坐东方快车。坐那辆火车穿越欧洲是他的梦想。所以那是我做过的最奢侈的事情。但那是在一辆豪华火车上。结果你最终并没有，你知道的，因为你从来没有在野外做过什么吗？
either of you guys well i did i did uh uh a days where the work schedule laugh on a night writer episode once they get in a honey wagon and honey wagons let me tell you something if you're looking to stretch out and catch a nap at lunch you're fucked yeah you are in the forest in the forest yeah that's hard yeah those those well you mean what your legs are straight up and they're they're flat your feet are flat against the wall you got the xylophon own wall that is just you're hearing everybody's business next door I don't recommend it
你们俩谁做过？嗯，我做过，我做过……有几天工作日程在《奈特骑士》（Night Rider）的一集里拉下了，他们上了房车（honey wagon）。房车，我跟你说，如果你想在午餐时躺下来小睡一会儿，那你可就完蛋了，对，你在森林里，在森林里，对，那很难，对，那些，你是说你的双腿伸得直直的，它们是平的，你的脚紧紧贴着木墙，你身边有木琴般的墙壁，你听得见隔壁所有人的私事，我不推荐。
you remember your roommate you remember who it was some old timer bless his heart not earn this portion Jack Elam maybe might have been Jack Elam I don't think yeah I would go if it was like
你还记得你的室友吗？你还记得他是谁吗？某个老派人物，上帝保佑他。不是厄恩（Earn）。这部分可能是杰克·埃兰（Jack Elam），也许是杰克·埃兰。我不觉得，对，如果那是像
you know the kids say glamping like if it was because I love to do I've done I did when I was your son's eight I was 15 I did a three and a half week canoe trip up in northern Ontario and that was 19 In 1985 and we got dropped off on the side of a road and it was, yeah, three and a half weeks of canoeing
孩子们说的“精致露营”（glamping）的话，我会去的，因为我喜欢做——我做过，我在你儿子八岁时，我15岁，我在安大略省北部进行了一次三周半的独木舟之旅，那是1985年，我们被扔在一条路的旁边，然后，是的，进行了三周半的独木舟之旅，
and it ended up being a whole thing and we got way behind because the maps were so old so we had to portage every day for the last eight days. Fortage. And we had to get rescued by. We paddled into this bay and we were like, we knew we were way behind and we had to meet a bus at a highway
结果搞得状况百出，由于地图太老，我们严重落后，所以在最后八天里，我们每天都得扛着独木舟徒步。扛舟。而且我们还得被营救。我们划进了一个海湾，我们当时觉得，我们知道自己严重落后，我们必须在一条高速公路上赶上一辆巴士，
and we knew we were hundreds of kilometers or miles or whatever behind. And we paddled into a bay You didn't see anybody And there was no roads up there There's nothing It was way up northern Ontario And we got
而且我们知道我们落后了成百上千公里或英里什么的。我们划进了一个海湾，你没看见任何人，那里也没有路，什么都没有。那是安大略省北部很深的地方。我们
We paddled around this corner There was a cabin there We saw some people there And they dropped Sometimes they drop people A lot of Americans off For fishing for a week On a seaplane
绕过这个海湾的拐角，那里有一间小屋。我们在那里看到了一些人。有时他们会用气球飞机把人投送到那里，
And there's a couple there And we paddled up to their dock And they're like Are you boys okay By the way I never let Mike We were all 15 And the two guides were 18 Right
让许多美国人去钓鱼一个星期。那里有一对夫妇，我们划到他们的码头边，他们问：“孩子们，你们还好吗？”顺便说一句，我从不让迈克——我们当时都15岁，两个向导18岁，对吧？
So the five five of us and then two guides and we're like we're kind of in trouble and at which point the plane that had that worked for that company drove by and saw our canoes and came and he landed and he said and asked us with the situation he said okay well we'll get in touch with somebody you know there's way before cell phones and all that shit and we were like what's going to happen and then like two hours later we see a twin otter come and land and it's the Ministry of Natural Resources and they picked us up and we strapped a couple of our canoes to the pontoons and we and we took off and we got out of there. The craziest thing was at the end of this
所以我们五个加上两个向导，我们就说我们遇到点麻烦了。就在这时，为那家公司工作的飞机飞过，看到了我们的独木舟，然后飞了过来，他降落了，询问了我们的情况，他说：“好吧，我们会跟某人取得联系的。”你知道的，那远在手机和其他破玩意儿出现之前。我们就问：“会发生什么？”然后大约两个小时后，我们看到一架双水獭飞机飞来并降落，那是自然资源部（Ministry of Natural Resources）的飞机，他们接了我们，把我们的几艘独木舟绑在浮筒上，然后我们就起飞了，离开了那里。最疯狂的事情是，在这个海湾的尽头，
bay, there were these two small islands really close together, and on each island was a wing. We're like, what's that? And they're like, oh, back in the 50s, a plane tried to take off it was too heavy and it didn't make it. They cheered off both wings. Oh, my God. And we're like, are we okay? And then the guy's like, you know, Bushpile
有两个离得很近的小岛，每个岛上都有一只飞机的机翼。我们当时想：“那是什么？”他们说：“哦，在50年代，曾有一架飞机试图起飞，但太重了，没飞起来。它把两个机翼都给撞断了。”天哪。我们当时想：“我们安全吗？”然后那个家伙就像丛林飞行员那样说：“哦，没事，我们会没事的，呃，不用担心。”
is like, oh yeah, we'll be fine, eh, no worries. Wow. Were you scared? Did you get, did you, do you remember that feeling? You know, about day, about day four of us being way behind we started to get a little bit scared it was really we were it was just we were out there and we was like nobody knew where we were and so anyway i couldn't eat when they broke for first team i had to wait until background i had to eat when background ate and i'm like guys i've got
哇。你当时害怕吗？你有没有，你有，你还记得那种感觉吗？你知道的，在我们严重落后的大概第四天，我们开始有点害怕了。真的，我们当时就是，我们在那儿，心想没人知道我们在哪儿。所以，不管怎样，当他们为第一组（first team）休息时，我没法吃东西，我必须等到背景演员（background）吃饭时我才能吃，我就跟他们说：“伙计们，我有台词，我今天还要说几句台词呢。”他们却说：“不行，我们要你留在我的场景里，对，留着待命，然后我们会通知你的，我们得先让第一组拍完。”我必须等到背景演员吃饭时才吃。但我挺过来了。我挺过来了。你挺过来了。哦，你看起来气色真好，杰伊。沃尔顿，你在佐治亚州长大的。
line i'm saying a couple lines today and they're like nope we're gonna want you to stay at my size yeah stay and holding and then we'll let you know we've got to get first team through first I had to eat one back round eight. But I made it. I made it. You made it. Oh, you look great, Jay. Walton, you grew up in Georgia.
我今天只说几句台词，他们就说‘不，我们要你保持我的尺寸，对，保持住并坚持，然后我们会通知你，我们得先让主力队过去。’我之前在第八轮吃了一个。但我撑过来了。我撑过来了。你撑过来了。哦，你看起来状态真棒，杰。沃尔顿，你在佐治亚州长大的。
Can you say anything specifically from that area that has shaped you into the kind of actor you are today? I mean, I guess you sort of, you basically said it. It's seasoned you a bit, right? I was going to say this. I don't know if it's Georgia, but also the way that you live your life and you're talking about the stuff you do, you have such an unbelievably freewheeling style and I mean that is the greatest as such a compliment
你能说出那个地方有什么特别之处，将你塑造成了今天这样的演员吗？我的意思是，我想你大概、你基本上已经说过了。它让你变得更有经验了，对吧？我正想这么说。我不知道这是不是因为乔治亚州，还是因为你生活的方式，当你谈到你所做的事情时，你有种不可思议的、随性不羁的风格，我是说，这绝对是极高的赞美。
you bring something to every sort of role that you do you bring this kind of, yeah, this life like this kind of freewheeling thing that is so fucking alive and fantastic every time you light it up man and I wonder if that is because of your background dude I've been exposed to stuff you know he's got things to draw on
你为你所扮演的每一种角色都带来了一些东西，你带来了这种，对，这种生命力，这种随性不羁的特质，每次你点燃全场时，那种感觉都生机勃勃、棒极了，老兄，我在想这是否是因为你的背景，伙计，你经历过各种事情，你知道的，他有东西可以汲取。
look that's a lot coming from this group of men because I am such big fans of all of you. As you know, I mean, Sean, you don't, but I am. Well, that's very sweet. Likewise. I, you know, this is what, I genuinely live every day like it's my last day. And what I mean by that is, you know, I know what it's like to be hungry. I know what it's like to be cold. I know what it's like to be uncomfortable.
听着，这群大老爷们能说出这话可真不容易，因为我是你们所有人的超级粉丝。如你所知，我是说，肖恩，你可能不知道，但我确实是。好吧，这太暖心了。彼此彼此。我，你知道，这就是，我真的把每一天都当作最后一天来过。我这么说是为了让你知道，我知道饥饿是什么滋味。我知道寒冷是什么滋味。我知道不舒服是什么滋味。
Yeah. I know now what it's like to wear really nice clothes. And so, like, because I've had this beautiful fun and got to wear the well, well. wear well that's very kind of you say but but i you know it's like well why why do you think these people are letting you wear these clothes i said because i'm wearing i'm like i'll never get to wear them again and that's the truth you know why you know we have a friend and i mean that and that's okay too we have you do have an allergy to buttons though and just like just like i do's got an allergy to sleeves sleeves yeah you're in a fight with the clothes you're not you're not you're not
是的。我现在知道穿真正好看的衣服是什么滋味了。所以，就像，因为我有了这段美好的乐趣，并且穿上了……穿得很好。穿得很好，你这么说太客气了，但是，但是我知道，就像，为什么，你为什么觉得这些人让你穿这些衣服？我说因为我穿着，我心想我再也穿不到了，这是实话，你知道为什么，你知道我们有个朋友，我是认真的，这也没关系，你对纽扣确实过敏，就像，就像我一样，有个对袖子过敏的家伙，袖子，是的，你在和衣服打架，你不是，你不是，你不是。
hey man i'm taking my cues off richard gear i'm taking my i'm taking my cue's i don't you know what i did a movie with Richard, man. I did a movie with Richard. This is a few years ago. And it was with Dinklage and Bradley. And we were sitting there and it was really, really tired. It was a long, long day. And I looked at him and I said,
嘿，老兄，我在向理查·基尔看齐，我在向我，我在向……我不知道，你知道吗，我跟理查拍过电影，老兄。我跟理查拍过电影。那是好几年前的事了。当时还有丁克拉奇和布拉德利。我们坐在那里，真的非常非常累。那是漫长、漫长的一天。我看着他说，
man, I'm so tired. I'm really tired. You must be tired, Richard. And he said, you know what? You're right. I am. I'm very tired. He said, but you know the difference between you and me? I said, no, man, what's the difference? He said, tomorrow morning when I wake up, I'll still be Richard Geer.
老兄，我太累了。我真的很累。理查，你一定也很累吧。他说，你知道吗？你说得对。我是很累。他说，但你知道你和我的区别吗？我说，不知道，老兄，有什么区别？他说，明天早上我醒来时，我依然是理查·基尔。
And you won't. You motherfucker, man. You're exactly right. You will be. So it's okay. You're okay. That's really funny. Now, all right.
而你不是。你这个混蛋，老兄。你说的太对了。你会是。所以没关系。你没事的。这太搞笑了。好了，现在。
So you pack up from George. You go to Georgia Southern University, I think I got that right. And you do a year there and you say, you want to know what? I think I know what I want to do. So you jump. Did you ride horse back from Georgia out to Los Angeles? Yeah, I did. I wrote a horse.
所以你从乔治亚收拾行李离开。你去了乔治亚南方大学，我想我没记错吧。你在那里读了一年，然后你说，你想知道吗？我想我知道我想做什么。于是你出发了。你是骑着马从乔治亚一路去洛杉矶的吗？是的，我骑了。我骑着马。
I've seen this entire nation. Yeah, I took a long way around. So I went to the northern route, then came back and they took the southern route just to get in LA. So you pull into Los Angeles there at 19. And what you start? you start the process of chasing the dream. And was it a difficult thing to get an agent and get auditions right away?
我见证了整个国家。是的，我绕了远路。我走了北方路线，然后回来，又走了南方路线，只为了到达洛杉矶。你在19岁时来到了洛杉矶。你开始了什么？你开始了追逐梦想的过程。找经纪人和立刻获得试镜机会是一件很困难的事吗？
Did you have a colorful first job to sort of pay the bills during this process? What was that first year? Well, you know, I was, I was, look, we all have our stories, right? I mean, there was no way I was ever going to go to New York. A vertically integrated city was way above my pay grade. I couldn't handle that living. Wait, wait, sorry, because you thought,
在这个过程中，你有没有一份多姿多彩的第一份工作来勉强维持生计？那第一年是怎样的？好吧，你知道，我，我，听着，我们都有自己的故事，对吧？我的意思是，我绝对不可能去纽约。一个垂直整合的城市远远超出了我的能力范围。我应付不了那种生活。等等，等等，抱歉，因为你觉得，
New York would be too expensive to live in? Well, too expensive, but so radically different, right? And I, and I, then, you know, the urban sprawl. Well, not sprawl, no. I grew up kind of like, you know, in the country with space, a little bit of space. And a big family, a little family? No, well, I mean, I, you know, I mean, I have a half brother now, but at the time, I mean, I was really kind of raised an only child, and it was my mom and her three sisters and my grandmother.
纽约生活成本太高了？嗯，太高了，而且跟我的生活方式天差地别，对吧？然后，然后，你知道，城市扩张。呃，也不是扩张，没有。我生长的地方有点像，你知道，在乡下，有空间，有一点点空间。是个大家庭还是小家庭？不，我的意思是，我，你知道，我的意思是，我现在有个同父异母的兄弟，但当时，我的意思是，我真的是由单亲妈妈抚养长大，家里只有我妈、她三个姐妹和我外婆。
And my cousin, who's like, you know, she's like my aunt's daughter, like my sister. And then all of these crazy, crazy southern hippies, you know, like all of these guys. I had just a lot of people that kind of came through my life. Right. So New York was too much of a cultural shock potentially. Well, you know, maybe on some level, absolutely. And I also think that I was just really attracted to the West, you know, and the idea. I'm, you know, growing up in a place where the biggest view that you have is a football field, right, because of all the pines and all the rest of it, I just love the idea of seeing from miles in any direction.
还有我表妹，她就像，你知道的，就像我阿姨的女儿，就像我亲妹妹一样。然后还有所有这些疯狂的、疯狂的南方嬉皮士，你知道，就像所有这些家伙。我生命中曾有过许多不同的人来来去去。对。所以对你来说纽约可能带来太大的文化冲击了。嗯，你知道，也许在某种程度上，绝对是。而且我也觉得我就是对西部情有独钟，你知道，还有那种开阔的感觉。我，你知道的，在一个最大的视野也超不过一个橄榄球场的地方长大，你知道的，因为到处都是松树和其他植物，我就是喜欢那种能向着任意方向眺望数英里的感觉。
And so, yeah, I left, you know, at 19, you know, drove across country and with my dad, believe it or not. Oh, right. You know, and I had, you know, a number. But I watched, I mean, I'm not without people in my life that were in this business. in the sense that my aunt was an actress in the theater and her husband, my uncle. So I grew up kind of watching them on stage. Sure.
所以，是的，我离开了，你知道，在19岁时，你知道，跟我爸一起开车横穿了美国，信不信由你。哦，对。你知道，我有，你知道，经历过一些事。但我见证过，我的意思是，我的生活中并非没有从事这行的人，我姑姑是位戏剧演员，她的丈夫也就是我叔叔。所以我从小是看着他们在舞台上表演长大的。当然。
And, but, you know, I really didn't, I mean, I liked doing this, you know? I mean, I did like to do. I didn't know this is what I was going to do for the rest of my life. I just really wanted to see the world. But when you landed day one, what do you do? Like, how do you, what was your plan? Well, I started working, right, in Atlanta. I mean, I started working like, there was a, yeah,
但是，你知道，我其实并没有，我的意思是，我喜欢做这个，你知道吗？我的意思是，我确实喜欢做这件事。我当时并不知道这就是我这辈子要从事的职业。我只是真的很想看世界。但当你第一天落地时，你要做什么？比如，你怎么，你的计划是什么？嗯，我开始工作了，对吧，在亚特兰大。我的意思是，我开始工作，就像，有那么一个，对，
like Kyle Chandler was this, you know, in this group, and my buddy Ray McKinnon, and just there was a lot kind of going on in Atlanta at that time. And I got a few gigs there. And one was a pretty big one, you know, called Murder in Mississippi. And it was nominated for like eight Golden Globes with a bunch of really great actors in it. And so I got an agent pretty quick, you know, because I'd come out kind of before. And they said, come on out. I mean, yeah, kind of that.
就像凯尔·钱德勒就在这群人里，还有我的好哥们雷·麦金农，当时亚特兰大有很多事情正在发生。我在那里接了几份零工。其中一份挺大的，你知道，叫《密西西比谋杀案》。它获得了大约八项金球奖提名，里面有一群非常优秀的演员。所以我很快就找到了经纪人，你知道的，因为我之前就稍微出过镜。他们说，来吧。我的意思是，对，差不多就是这样。
I mean, I don't know. They were kind of reluctant. I mean, I don't know why they took me, to be quite honest with you. But I, you know, I didn't know, I mean, I had a guy's phone number, and I, when I first got dropped off at the Oak Woods. No, I got dropped off at this woman. I met, I worked with her husband, and she was like a manager, and I actually put this, like, on my inside version of it on my Instagram, but I got dropped off at this apartment woman, her husband picked me up, and I got back to her apartment, like, right off like Sierra Bonita in Hollywood Boulevard. And, you know, she asked me to sign this paper, and I said, I just, I don't really know. I don't think I should do that.
我的意思是，我不知道。他们有点勉强。我的意思是，老实说我不知道他们为什么会选我。但我，你知道，我不知道，我当时只有一个人的电话号码，当我第一次被送到橡树森林公寓时。不，我是被送到一个女人那儿。我跟她丈夫合作过，她是个经纪人。我其实把这事儿发到了我的Instagram的私密版本里。但我被送到这个女人的公寓，她丈夫开车接的我，我回到了她的公寓，就在好莱坞大道西拉博尼塔路附近。然后，你知道，她让我签这张纸，我说，我只是，我真的不知道。我觉得我不该签这个。
I don't even know what I am. And she said, well, you know, if you don't sign it, then you have to leave. I said, well, I don't have anywhere to go. And she said, well, you've got to figure that out. I said, well, can I just spend the night? I'll be out of here first thing in the morning. She said, yeah. And I left, you know, first thing the next morning.
我都不知道自己是个什么定位。她说，好吧，你知道，如果你不签，那你得离开。我说，好吧，我无处可去。她说，好吧，那得你自己想办法。我说，那我能在这过夜吗？我一大早就会离开这儿。她说，行。然后我走了，你知道，第二天一大早。
And I had an audition, actually, with a cast director by the name of Pam Dixon. And I sat, I was there, you know, four and a half hours early. and with my luggage, and she said, boy, you've been out here the whole time? I said, yeah, you know, she'll just bring your stuff inside, just hang out. And I did and didn't get the job. But afterwards, I had a phone number
其实我当时有个试镜，和一个名叫帕姆·迪克森的选角导演。我坐在那儿，比预定时间早了整整四个半小时，带着我的行李。她说，孩子，你在这儿待了这么久吗？我说，对啊，你知道的。她说，那就把你的东西拿进来，随便呆着吧。我照做了，但没得到那份工作。不过在那之后，我有一个电话号码，
from a guy that I'd worked with and I ran into it a Rio Bravo in Atlanta and I called it and he answered the phone, a pay phone, right? And he said, yeah, man, I'll come pick you up and you can stay with us. And that was kind of it. Wow. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
是我一个合作过的伙伴的，我在亚特兰大的里奥布拉沃偶遇了他，我拨了那个号码，他接了电话，是个公用电话，对吧？他说，行啊，老兄，我来接你，你可以跟我们住在一起。事情基本上就是这样。哇。对，对，对。
And, I mean, I had 300 bucks, you know, in my pocket. Yeah. And then got a job like everybody else, you know. What job? What were you doing? LA Fitness. Sure. You know, 5 a.m. to 9 a.m. shift, making full bucks an hour.
而且，我的意思是，我口袋里只有300块钱，你知道的。然后像其他人一样找了份工作。什么工作？你在做什么？LA Fitness（洛杉矶健身房）。当然。你知道的，早上5点到9点的班，一小时赚四块钱。
Were you checking folks in or were you a personal trainer? Checking them in, man. Yeah. Yeah. Giving them locker keys. Yeah. Like, there was nobody there. Just me.
你是负责登记还是当私人教练？登记员，老兄。对，对。发储物柜钥匙。对。就像，那里根本没人。只有我。
Yeah. Do you remember where that was, which L.A. Fitness that was? Yeah. Oxnard and Coal Water. Oh, in the Valley. Yeah. Oh, with the racquetball courts. I used to play racquetball in there.
对。你还记得那是哪里吗，是哪家洛杉矶健身房？对，奥克斯纳德和科尔沃特交界处。哦，在峡谷区。对。哦，有壁球场的那家。我以前经常在那里打壁球。
Oh, did you. As a matter of fact, they did. Yeah, did they have that? Sure, they must have right there. On the L.A. River. On the L.A. River. Would you play there with Schwartz? Yeah, Johnny Schwartz.
哦，是吗？事实上，确实有。对，他们有那个吗？当然，在那儿肯定得有。在洛杉矶河边。在洛杉矶河边。你会和施瓦茨一起在那里打球吗？对，强尼·施瓦茨。
Johnny Schwartz? Did you guys play there? He'd kick my ass every day. And where were you living at that point? I mean, were you living at the top of the Sunset Tower? That's where he kept his course. That's where you started your journey in Los Angeles. Listen, I will say, Walton, it's not surprising.
强尼·施瓦茨？你们一起打过吗？他每天都把我打得落花流水。那你当时住在哪里？我的意思是，你当时住在日落塔酒店顶层吗？那是他存枪的地方。那是你在洛杉矶之旅的起点。听着，沃尔顿，我得说，这并不奇怪。
Again, I'm going to get down to what I know from you, over the years and that you, that this stuff opened up because you come at life with such a great positive attitude and it is a really great, not to get too weird,
再说一次，我要结合这些年来我对你的了解来说，这些事情之所以能有进展，是因为你对待生活有着如此积极伟大的态度，这真是一个非常棒的例子——这话听起来可能有点奇怪，
but it is a great example of you come out, you just, you make a call, you're open, you're very positive, and you kind of get in life what you put into it. And it's almost like, I think that that lesson,
但这真的是一个极好的例子：你来到这里，你只是打了个电话，你保持开放的心态，你非常积极，你付出了什么，生活就会给予你什么。这几乎就像，我认为这个教训，
again, that you gave your son, I mean, this is all part of a bigger, if you kind of take a broader view, that you've just got this great vibe. And again, I just, it's no surprise to me, man. People want to hang out with you. Yeah. Yeah.
再次说明，你传授给你儿子的经验，我的意思是，如果你把眼光放得更远大一些，这一切其实都属于一个更宏大的层面——你拥有如此棒的正能量。再说一次，我一点也不觉得意外，老兄。大家都想跟你混在一起。对，对。
Well, I mean, look, look, we all have our path, right? And what, you know, how did we, how did we get that first job? How did we get a second job? How do we get a third? How did a decade later? 20 years later. I mean, hell, we have, I've been at this 30, 30 something years, 35 years. And I, and I, you know, I don't, I just don't compare myself to anybody else really.
好吧，我的意思是，听着，听着，我们都有自己的路，对吧？还有什么，你知道的，我们是怎么得到第一份工作的？我们是怎么得到第二份工作的？我们是怎么得到第三份的？十年后呢？二十年以后呢？我的意思是，见鬼，我们，我已经干了30、30多年了，35年了。我，而且我，你知道，我不，我真的不和任何人作比较。
Yeah, that's so crucial, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, and I've got, like, we have a lot of friends in common. I've got a lot of friends who are a lot more successful than I am and a lot that aren't. And but it's the same, right? Sure.
对，这太关键了，不是吗？对。对。是的，我有，就像，我们有很多共同的朋友。我有很多朋友比我成功得多，也有很多不如我成功。但都是一样的，对吧？当然。
We're all the same, yeah. Yeah, it is. I mean, we really are. It is. Sean would say something interesting because we were talking about this thing I went to the other night, and Sean said, isn't it funny that no matter what, we, on a certain level, nobody thinks that they've made it.
我们都一样，对吧。是的，确实如此。我的意思是，我们真的是一样的。确实如此。肖恩会说一些有趣的话，因为我们聊起了我前天晚上去参加的一个活动，肖恩说，不管怎样，从某种程度上讲，没有人觉得自己真正成功了，这不是很搞笑吗？
I don't care who you are, because you're always trying to, right right you're always there's no like people like oh you made it like i haven't made it i'm like thinking about right how do i right and everybody else think they say and uh it's this great line i just saw the movie jay kelly which is pretty good uh george clini says you know that he spent his whole life trying to get something that he thought he really wanted and then he got it and then he realized oh wait it's not over i got to now i got to keep it you know it's like so no matter where you are even if you think you're there you still got to work on trying to keep it if you care to you Do you think they'll put your quote?
我不管你是谁，因为你总是在努力……对，对，你总是在那儿……没有那种“哦，人们觉得你成功了”，就像我还没成功，我心里想的总是“好，我该怎么做呢”，然后其他所有人都觉得他们成功了，呃，这有一句很棒的台词，我刚看了电影《杰·凯利》，挺不错的，呃，乔治·克鲁尼说，你知道，他花了一生时间去追求他以为自己真正想要的东西，然后他得到了，接着他意识到，哦，等等，还没结束，我必须现在，我必须守住它。你知道，就像不管你在哪里，即使你觉得你已经到达了顶点，如果你在乎的话，你仍然得努力去守住它。你觉得他们会把你的名言写在海报上吗？
Do you think they'll put your quote on the poster, J.B. J. Kelly, pretty good. Pretty good. Why not? On the back? Yeah, on Sunset Boulevard. You know? There it is. It's pretty good.
你觉得他们会把你的名言写在海报上吗，J.B.？《杰·凯利》，挺不错的。挺不错的。为什么不呢？印在背面？对，在日落大道上。你知道吗？就是这样。挺不错的。
I highly recommend. Can I ask you gentlemen something? Capricorn. Do you ever, do you get insecure walking into a room? I mean, yes, in general. Every day. Every day. Every moment.
我极力推荐。我能问各位绅士一个问题吗？摩羯座。你们走进一个房间时，会有不安全感吗？我是说，是的，通常来说。每天。每天。每一刻。
Walking into a room? Walking into a room with, you know, like, Like an event or like a bunch of actors or writers or directors or, you know, like something affiliated with this. 100% of the time. I don't get insecure about status because I don't care about it. I get insecure about carrying a conversation. Carrying a conversation. Yeah.
走进一个房间？走进一个有很多……比如像一个活动，或者有一群演员、作家、导演，或者，你知道，诸如此类的场合。100%会。我对地位没有不安全感，因为我不在乎地位。我担心的是能不能维持对话。维持对话。对。
Really? Yeah, yeah. You're an incredible conversation. No, no. But the work that it takes for me to get up to being a good conversationalist is exhausting. It's exhausting. Yeah, it's exhausting being interesting. and somebody you don't,
真的吗？对，对。你是个出色的对话者。不，不。但为了成为一个好的对话者，我所付出的努力是让人精疲力竭的。太累人了。对，要做一个有趣的人真的很累。
you're sitting next to to a table with placards with your name on it next to somebody you don't know and you have to like, start out from scratch. Hey, what's going on? Like, you know what I mean?
而且有个人你并不认识，
So I get anxiety about that, but not so much about like status. I don't care about status. No, not anymore. Weirdly, I think it's a, I think that I'm just naive and I don't know what it is that I'm blessed with that.
你坐在桌旁，桌上有写着你名字的席卡，旁边坐着一个你不认识的人，你必须从零开始。嘿，最近怎么样？就像，你知道我的意思吗？
It's kind of, you know, they're just like, I just don't have any sense. Yeah, I had a really cool, I was doing this interview thing the other day it's going to come out but that um and i was i had the pleasure of sitting next to benito del toro and uh well that's somebody i would like to sit next yeah and the woman said uh she said you know this idea of imposter's syndrome she said do you ever um do you guys ever have the
所以我对那种事感到焦虑，但对地位没那么多感觉。我不在乎地位。不，不再在乎了。奇怪的是，我觉得这是一种，我觉得我只是比较天真，我不知道自己是有什么福气，
suffer from imposter syndrome and she said benicho and he goes what is that and i was like oh man that's wild that's so dope and she goes no you know that thing and he goes I don't know what that is. I was like, fuck. Yeah. That would make me feel even more of an imposter. But it was so dope. It was sitting me over the edge.
就像，你知道的，他们只是觉得，我就是没心没肺。对，我有个很酷的经历，前几天我在做这样一个采访，节目快要播出了，但那个……我有幸坐在本尼西奥·德·托罗旁边，呃……好吧，那是我想坐在一起的人。对。然后那位女士说，呃，她说，你知道冒名顶替综合征这个概念吗？她说你们有没有……
But at the same time, it was so cool because it was such a great sort of lesson of like you don't have to, right? Like you can try to, you can kind of let that go. And he has it naturally in the most beautiful way, but like, oh yeah, you don't have to have it.
遭受过冒名顶替综合征的困扰？她说本尼西奥怎么说？他说那是什么？当时我就想，哦天哪，这太酷了，太帅了。然后她说，不，你知道那种感觉。他说我不知道那是什么。我当时想，靠。这让我觉得自己更像个冒名顶替者了。但这太酷了。简直把我惊艳到了。
You know? That's right. Yeah. Yeah. You know, I've gotten aware, like, you know, I've just gotten, And it scares me a little bit, you know, but I've gotten really comfortable at work. Yeah, it doesn't, you know what I mean?
但与此同时，这又太酷了，因为这是一个很好的教训，告诉你，你其实不必——对吧？就像你可以试着，你可以把那种情绪放下。他以最美妙的方式自然而然地做到了这一点，但就像，“哦，是的，你不需要有这种感觉。”
And I, and that's not a feeling that I'm comfortable with. I like to be, when I'm working, I'm not very social. I'm alone. I'm just off doing my thing. Yeah, I like that. And then you kind of come in. I don't hang out and just small talk. I don't have the energy.
你知道吗？没错。对。对。你知道的，我开始意识到，就像，你知道的，我只是变得——这让我有点害怕，你知道吗，但我开始在工作中感到非常自在。是的，这并没有，你知道我的意思吗？
I'm like you, Sean. I get exhausted. Yeah, me too. I'm an introvert for sure. sure yeah yeah but you know what david you know famous david i just looked it up the david bowie it's i love this it's you probably know it aging is an extraordinary process whereby you become the person you always should have been yeah so all of this stuff that we're talking about i think the older you get the more you're like i can walk into a room because who gives a shit like i just had
而且，我不习惯这种感觉。我喜欢在工作时保持孤立，不太社交。我喜欢独处。我只是在做我自己的事。是的，我喜欢那样。然后你才会融入进来。我不会到处闲逛说废话。我没有那个精力。
i just had an extraordinary i just had an extraordinary experience and i who knows it will translate but i am up here doing this thing where are you by the way man i'm in i'm in i'm outside of i'm in montes outside of Bozeman, Montana. He's in the back of an in and out. And I'm doing this. I have the pleasure of doing these scenes with the great Michelle Pfeiffer. Jay, what do you call her?
我跟你一样，肖恩。我也精疲力竭。对，我也是。我绝对是个内向的人。确定，对，对。但你知道吗，大卫，你知道著名的大卫，我刚刚查了一下，是大卫·鲍伊的，我太喜欢这句话了，你可能也知道：“衰老是一个非凡的过程，在这个过程中，你成为了你本该成为的那个人。”是的，所以我们讨论的所有这些事情，我觉得你年纪越大，你就会越觉得：“我完全可以走进这个房间，因为谁特么在乎呢，我刚刚经历了一个——”
M-Fifee-Five. Mishie-Feefe. And she's so brilliant. And I just had this moment, and I think it's age. I don't know if it's age or what it is. And I could just say it, honestly, that I was just there doing this thing, and we're literally shooting on the edge
我刚刚经历了一个非凡的——我刚刚经历了一段非凡的经历，谁知道它会不会转化为银幕上的呈现呢？但我正坐在高处做这件事。顺便问一下你在哪儿，老兄？我在，我在……我在蒙大拿州博兹曼市外的蒙特斯。他正坐在一家汽车旅馆的后方。而我正在做这个。我有幸能与伟大的米歇尔·菲佛同场飙戏。杰，你平时怎么叫她？
of this river that's out there, this beautiful. It's just, what I'm looking at, is insanely beautiful and then snow cap mountains in the distance and the thing and uh we're about to go and i'm like what am i doing in the scene and what am i doing and i just went like oh man i literally was like anything can happen just enjoy just be right here yeah and then it was just like unreal yeah i'm just like letting go and i don't think i could have done it as a younger man and i think that as i'm getting older i've just let go of so many hangups so yeah because well because you asked that do you have that because you asked us that do you have
M-Fifee-Five（米·菲菲·菲夫）。米什·菲菲。她太才华横溢了。我刚刚经历了这个时刻，我想这是年龄带来的。我不知道这是不是因为年纪或是别的什么。我可以很诚实地说，我当时就在那里演这场戏，我们真的是在河边拍戏，那条河就在那里，美极了。我眼前的景色美得发疯，远处的山峰白雪皑皑，还有那个啥，呃……我们正要开拍，我心想：我在演什么场景？我在做什么？然后我脑子里就冒出一个念头：哦，天哪，我 literalmente（字面意思/简直）心想，任何事情都可能发生，只要享受当下，就在这里。然后一切就变得不真实了，对。我只是选择放手，我觉得年轻时的我是做不到这一点的。我觉得随着年龄增长，我终于放下了太多的精神枷锁，所以，是的——因为你问了这个问题，你也有这种感觉吗？因为你问了我们，你还有吗？你还在……
have? Are you still? Well, I guess what I was kind of getting at, just to hear your experiences. Yeah, I think that I just carried so much of the people that I've gotten to play. You know, they're pretty lonely, you know. They're, you know, nefarious, and they've got a lot going on, and they're under a lot of pressure mentally and emotionally for the most part. And so I quite enjoy kind of being in that state. place, especially, you know, at work.
还是那样吗？好吧，我想我刚才想表达的是，只是想听听你们的经历。是的，我觉得我身上承载了太多我扮演过的角色的影子。你知道的，他们其实挺孤独的。他们，你知道，穷凶极恶，脑子里装了很多事，而且在精神和情感上大都背负着巨大的压力。所以我其实挺享受那种状态的，尤其是，你知道，在工作的时候。
But, you know, something happened recently where, where it's similar, but I just showed up like, yeah, hi, how are you? And I was just not, and I was there, I'd read the script 250 times. I know what's happening. But I, all of a sudden, I just didn't need that anymore. I mean, it's like the difference between, you know, your 20s and your 30s and then for me becoming a father at 39, so let's call it 40s, and then learning how to be a parent, oh god oh god now i'm a parent i'm in my 50s and i'm and that's okay i'm i know how to be a parent
但是，你知道，最近发生了一件事，虽然情况类似，但我只是表现得像：“嗨，你好吗？”我当时没有想太多，我就在那儿，剧本我已经读了250遍了。我知道接下来会发生什么。但突然之间，我不再需要那些紧绷感了。我的意思是，这就像是你20多岁和30多岁时的区别，然后对我来说，是在39岁时当了父亲，我们就暂且称之为40多岁吧，然后学习如何当一个父母，“哦天哪，哦天哪，我现在是个父母了，我都50岁了，而且没关系，我知道怎么当一个父母了”。
yeah i feel like i i i know how to tell stories and i just enjoy it more than i've i've ever enjoyed it so it's just a new experience for me right like i don't i don't have that but it's freeing though right it is so free man yeah i love it is it's so free i love it we'll be right back and now back to the show well do you feel that um because you know we're we do this thing where we're playing people and i think i think all four of us are interested in playing people that that don't have it all together people that are that are that are somewhat broken and an interesting way and vulnerable and human and have flaws and all that stuff and have you have you felt like you've you know
对，我觉得我，我，我知道怎么讲故事了，我比以往任何时候都更享受其中，所以这对我来说真是一个全新的体验，对吧？就像我不再有那种感觉了，但这让人感觉好解放，对吧？真的太解放了，老兄。是的，我爱死这种感觉了，太解放了，我爱极了。我们马上回来，现在回到节目中。好吧，你觉得，呃，因为你知道，我们在做演员这一行，我们在扮演各种各样的人，而且我认为我们四个都对扮演那些不够完美的人感兴趣，那些生活有点破碎、以一种有趣的方式脆弱、有人性、有缺点等等的人。你有没有觉得，你知道的——
we're talking about as we get older we get better right Just as people. So do you think that that's at odds with playing characters that don't have it all together? Like, as we're starting to get our shit together as we get older, it's sort of at odds with playing characters that are a little bit broken. And then, in fact, as you get more and more successful maybe,
我们刚才在谈论随着年龄增长我们变得更好了，对吧？作为人而言。所以你认为这与扮演那些生活一团糟的角色相矛盾吗？就像，随着我们随着年龄增长开始把生活过得井井有条，这跟去扮演那些有点破碎的角色其实是有些矛盾的。然后，事实上，随着你可能越来越成功，
you know, as we were joking about earlier, you kind of get a little bit soft because things are sort of privileged around you and luxurious and stuff. Is it, do you fight that? of embrace of success? Does it go against what you like to live in? You know what? That's a great question. I would ask you all to answer that question too, but because I think we're told a lie
你知道的，就像我们刚才开玩笑说的，你可能会变得有点娇气，因为你身边的一切都被特权化、奢华化了。你会去抗拒这种对成功的拥抱吗？它会违背你喜欢沉浸其中的状态吗？你知道吗？这是一个很好的问题。我也想请你们所有人都回答这个问题，因为我觉得我们早期被灌输了一个谎言：
early on that you've got to struggle, you've got to live in it. You have to be fucked up to play fucked up people. The truth is, no man, you don't You can just be really evolved and not create distance between yourself and that experience actually really empathize with these people. And I think that's where I've gotten to in my life. And outside of, I generally empathize with human beings. I believe that all of our paths are by nature narcissistic. We cast ourselves as the antagonist and the protagonist and our own.
你必须挣扎，你必须身处苦难之中。你必须心理扭曲才能演心理扭曲的人。但事实是，不，老兄，你不需要。你可以变得非常进化，并且不需要将自己与那种体验拉开距离，事实上，你可以真正地与这些人共情。我想这就是我目前在生活中达到的状态。抛开其他不谈，我通常能对人类产生共情。我相信我们所有人的成长轨迹，本质上都是自恋的。我们在自己的故事里把自己塑造成反派和主角，
story and we just watch how we interface with the fucking world. When you step outside of that, when you really step outside of that narcissistic DNA quality of survival, all of a sudden the world just becomes, it's just easier. Life is easier.
然后我们只是观察我们是如何与这见鬼的世界进行互动的。当你跳出这一点，当你真正跳出那种求生本能的自恋DNA属性时，突然之间，世界就变得更简单了。生活变得更容易了。
It's just calmer. And I'm calmer. And I feel that happening kind of in my professional life. It's happened. God, I had such a hard time. I I'll watch you guys on Kimmel, you know, the three of you on Kimmel.
更加平静了。我能感觉到这种改变正在我的职业生涯中发生。它已经发生了。天哪，我以前经历过太难的时期。我看着你们在吉米秀上的节目，你知道的，你们三个在吉米秀上。
And I listened, I saw you, Sean, and I saw, like, how far, you know, you sat and kind of speaking about your anxiety. And I had, I still have it on, you know, on some level, but I had it. I really had it. It's also a little bit of a superpower, but yeah. It is a superpower. And getting ready to walk into a room for people that experienced that, and it's like, okay, I'm going to show, because I show up for shit.
我听着，我看着你，肖恩，我看到，你知道的，你坐在那儿，谈论着你的焦虑。我曾经也有，现在在某种程度上仍然有，但我以前真的有。这也是一种超能力，不过话又说回来。这确实是一种超能力。对于那些经历过那种感觉的人来说，准备好走进一个房间，心里就会想：好吧，我要展现出最好的一面，因为我对重要的事情从不马虎。
You know what I mean? I show up for a conversation and nothing is half-ass. That's right. I show up for everything. And if you put that much into it, if you care that much about it, well, then it's not performative. It's not a performance. But it takes a lot from you.
你知道我的意思吗？我对待对话总是全力以赴，绝不半途而废。没错。我为所有事情全力以赴。如果你为此付出了那么多，如果你对它如此在意，那么这就不是表演性质的。这不是一场演戏。但这也确实消耗了你很多精力。
And on the other side of that, you know, you've got to just be alone and quiet and kind of do all of that. And I envy people that can just fucking move through it, man. Right, without expending like a ton of energy and still be just as charming and all the rest. I know. I know me too. Yeah, but I wonder if that, because there have been times when I have been less insecure and really kind of just cruise through it and not really. And I just don't feel like, well, I might have a lesser level of anxiety. I just don't feel like I'm participating as much. I don't feel like I'm feeling the day as much. I like I like being insecure in as many things and situations as I can. I just feel like I'm a little bit more eyes open. ears open, heart open, if I am, like, I worry when I get too comfortable. Anyway, all right, so you, so you come out to L.A., you start working.
而在那之后，你知道的，你必须独自一人保持安静，把这些情绪都消化掉。我很羡慕那些能够轻而易举地度过难关的人，老兄。对，不需要消耗大量的精力，却依然能保持迷人以及其他所有特质。我懂。我懂，我也是。是的，但我怀疑，因为有时候我其实没那么不安全感，能真正地轻松过关，而不是太……而且我只是觉得，好吧，我可能会有较低程度的焦虑，但我只是觉得自己参与得没那么深了。我觉得我对每一天的感受没那么真切了。我喜欢在尽可能多的事情和情况下保持不安全感。我觉得只要我这么做，我的眼睛就会睁得更大，耳朵张得更开，心门也敞得更开。我担心自己变得太舒服。无论如何，好吧，所以你，所以你来到洛杉矶，你开始工作。
Do you remember what that job was that gave you a little bit of like a, oh, wow, I think I might be able to make a living at this. Some people have raised some eyebrows. I'm getting some calls. Was there one that kind of initiated the momentum that you've kept going? since then? Yeah, yeah, yeah, very specific, right? We've all had many before this happened and after this happened events in our life.
你还记得那是哪份工作让你产生了一点点这样的感觉吗：“哦，哇，我想我可能真的能靠这个谋生了。有些人开始注意到我了。我接到一些电话了。”有没有哪一部作品为你之后一直延续的势头开了一个好头？是的，是的，是的，非常具体，对吧？在这件事发生之前和之后，我们的人生中都经历过许多次大事件。
And I Valley Parked, I sold cowboy boots, then I became a personal trainer at the same gym that I started this thing, I did all of that. And then I got this movie called The Apostle with Robert DeVall. Oh, my God, so good, you're so good, and I love that movie, you were great. But I was 24 years old. And it was through the process of kind of telling that story
我做过代客泊车，卖过牛仔靴，然后成了我开始演艺生涯的那家健身房的私人教练，这些我都干过。后来我接拍了一部电影叫《传教士》（The Apostle），合作演员是罗伯特·杜瓦尔。哦，天哪，太棒了，你演得太好了，我太喜欢那部电影了，你演得很棒。但我当时才24岁。正是通过讲述那个故事的过程，
and the relationship that I had with Bobby on the other side of that that I felt like, okay, I can, you know what, man, because I always were. And I worked as soon as I got here. I was very, very fortunate. And I, you know, poor kid, Georgia, I just squirled it away, always. And just lived off whatever I made, doing whatever job that I was doing. But at that point, I thought, well, you know what?
以及在那之后我和鲍比建立的关系，让我觉得，好吧，你知道吗，老兄，因为我一直都在。而且我一到这里就开始工作了。我非常非常幸运。而且，你知道的，作为一个来自乔治亚州的穷小子，我总是把钱存起来。只靠我赚的钱生活，无论做什么工作都行。但在那个节点上，我想，好吧，你知道吗？
I'm just going to, I'm not going to do that anymore. and I'm just going to, you know, focus kind of on this. And then, you know, I don't think people really knew what to do with me because on the other side of that, thinking my manager, who was actually sitting here was my manager then. Nice. And she, you know, leaned in my ear or somebody that she was with leaned in my ear and said, hey, man, your life's about to change.
我再也不那样做了，我要，你知道的，专注于这个。然后，你知道的，我觉得人们其实不知道该怎么定位我，因为在那之后，我想我的经纪人——当时正坐在我身边的这位就是我当时的经纪人。太棒了。然后她，你知道的，凑到我耳边，或者跟她在一起的某个人凑到我耳边说：“嘿，老兄，你的人生要改变了。”
That's good, because it was a Toronto Film Festival or whatever. And then on the other side of it, people just thought, well, this guy's just fucking from there. They just got like he's just a local hire. Oh, they thought you weren't even like, you weren't even like an actor. You were a real. Yeah, exactly. It's like, oh, okay. What a compliment.
这挺好的，因为那是在多伦多电影节还是什么地方。但在这件事的另一面，人们只是觉得，嗯，这家伙就是特么从那儿来的。他们只是觉得他就像是个本地招募的演员。哦，他们以为你甚至都不是，你甚至都不算是个演员。你是个真正的……对，没错。就像，哦，好吧。这可真是极高的赞美。
Well, I guess it is to Bobby DeVall, you know, that's what he says. But, and then I just kept cruising, you know, I just said yes in life more than I said no. And I, you know, my 20s weren't under a microscope. I just got to do my thing. Yeah. But now, but now when you walk down the street, you're getting stopped. Yeah. And you have, you have been for, for years.
好吧，我想对鲍比·杜瓦尔来说确实如此，你知道，他就是这么说的。但随后我只是继续顺风顺水地发展，你知道，我对生活说“好”的时候比说“不”的时候多。而且，你知道的，我的20多岁并没有在显微镜下度过。我只是在做我自己的事。是的。但现在，但是现在当你走在街上时，你会被人拦下来。是的。而且你已经，你已经经历这些好几年了。
but how is what's your relationship with with that um do you feel like those are two separate people the the person that the public uh recognizes wants to talk to or have you have you have you been able to incorporate that into what seems to be an incredibly authentic person from the very beginning you've you've been very tapped into keeping it real not being full of shit no artifice um no veneer uh yet the public basically has a say on who they think you are as well. And sometimes fame, there's a, there's a, there's a, there's a, there's a discomfort with, with, with merging those two things.
但是，你是如何处理这种关系的呢？你觉得这是两个人吗，一个是公众认识、想要交谈的那个公众人物，另一个是你自己？还是你已经，你已经能够把这种成名融入到你从一开始就表现出的极其真实的真我之中？你一直非常注重保持真实，不做作，没有虚伪，没有外在的矫饰，然而公众对你究竟是谁其实也有他们的看法。有时名气会带来一种与融合这两者相关的别扭感。
Have you, have you made a fan of that or, oh, you know what, I honestly, and I, whether you like it or whether you don't, whether you don't, whether you like me or you don't like me, I am me. Yeah, yeah. And I, I am me privately. I am me publicly. Anybody that knows me very, very well listening to this podcast would say, yeah, He's the exact same.
你是否，你已经适应了这种状态，或者，哦，你知道吗，老兄，说实话，不管你喜欢与否，不管你喜欢我还是不喜欢我，我就是我。对，对。而且，我私下里是我，公开露面时也是我。任何非常非常了解我、在听这个播客的人都会说：“对，他完全没变。”
And, like, you know, interfacing with people on the street, this is no bullshit. Like, no, because editing yourself everywhere you go is exhausting, too. It's like, oh, I got to be this person who's not full of shit, who's no BS would be at a dinner table and enjoying your conversation with your friend. And then a fan would come up and ask for a picture or something. The person who's like, truly no bullshit would say, hey, man, I'm having dinner. I can't do that right now. But this is like an example.
而且，就像，你知道的，在街上和人们互动，这绝对不是废话。不，因为到处伪装自己也是一件很累的事。这就像是：“哦，我必须表现得像个不虚伪、不扯淡的人。”假设你正在晚宴上和朋友愉快地聊天，然后一个粉丝走过来要求合影什么的。一个真正不扯淡的人会说：“嘿，老兄，我正在吃饭，现在没办法配合。”但这只是个例子。
Kurt Russell would say that. Kurt Russell did say that. He called somebody out who said, like, I'm a pilot. And he's like, no, you're fucking not. You're not a pilot? Tell me about this thing. But that's not my personality. That's not where I come from.
库尔特·拉塞尔就会这么说。库尔特·拉塞尔确实说过。他曾当面指出过某个人的谎言，那人说：“我是个飞行员。”库尔特说：“不，你特么根本不是。你不是个飞行员？跟我说说这事儿。”但这并不是我的性格。这不是我出身的背景。
That's not how I was raised. And for me, and I really mean this, man. When I'm stopped on the street, yeah, I mean, it has been a lot. And it has been a lot over the last two or three years. But honestly, man, I feel like I can provide for my family. It just means that somebody else is going to hire me. And we have a public job. That's part of the job.
这不是我被抚养长大接受的教育。对我而言，我是认真的，老兄。当我在街上被人拦住时，是的，我的意思是，这种情况确实很多。而且在过去的两三年里真的非常多。但老兄，说实话，我觉得我能养家糊口，这意味着还会有人愿意雇佣我。我们做的是一份面向公众的工作。这是工作的一部分。
It is part of the job. And I genuinely love meeting people. I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't, I don't, I just, I don't, I live my life differently in that way. And I, and I don't, I never meet a stranger. I like, you know, even where we live now, which is radically different than where we've lived our entire life. You know, I wasn't, my friends are the painter and the plumber and then, and the artist and all the rest of it. But that's, man, listen, I was raised in a household with crazy fucking southern hippies. Yeah.
这确实是工作的一部分。而且我真心喜欢结识新朋友。我不会，我不会，我不会……我只是，我对待生活的方式不一样。我从来不觉得有什么人是彻头彻尾的陌生人。我喜欢，你知道的，甚至就像我们现在住的地方，那和我们一辈子生活过的地方有着天壤之别。你知道的，我的朋友有油漆工、水管工、艺术家以及各种各样的人。但那，老兄，听着，我是在一个到处都是疯狂的南方嬉皮士的家庭里长大的。对。
Crazy. Like, insane. And with love. With love. Yeah. Oh, absolutely. But certifiably and insane in the best way. And we all are.
疯狂的。简直疯狂。但充满了爱。充满爱。对，绝对的。但那是一种以最好的方式展现出来的名副其实的疯狂。我们全家都这样。
Like a Christmas at our house, like, you know, one little heater or whatever, more often than not, somebody would go to the store and then whoever went to the store would come back with. with three or four people. And that would happen to a couple of people would come back. So then all of a sudden, like in a family of whatever, there would be like 25 people sitting around our Christmas tree
就像在我们家过圣诞节，你知道的，只有一个小暖炉什么的，十有八九，总有人会去商店，然后去商店的那个人就会带回三四个人。这种情况会发生好几次，有人会带人回来。所以突然之间，在一个不管多少人的家庭里，圣诞树周围可能会坐着25个人，
that were, you know, when we had food. And then we would go, because we didn't have gifts for them, we would just go pick out, you know. I remember giving my Atari, like pitfall game to somebody. Just like my mom said, just go in there and pick out something you can give away. And I went in and wrapped it up in a, Christmas present I'd just been playing it like in like all morning and you know and gave it out like that's that's kind of what we did and and that's you know I don't know it's just kind of how I live my my life I love that way I just wanted to ask well like you know we could go through tons of your stuff hateful A Django Cowboys and Aliens the unicorn like all those great things that you've done shield and anyway it's on and on but only because it's the big recent
他们是，你知道的，当时我们有吃的。然后我们会去，因为我们没有给他们的礼物，我们就去挑，你知道的。我记得把我的雅达利（Atari）游戏机，就像《Pitfall》（陷阱卡带）那种游戏送给某个人。就像我妈妈说的：“去屋里挑个你能送人的东西吧。”然后我走进去，用圣诞包装纸把它包起来——我早上还在那儿玩呢，你知道的——然后把它送出去了。事情就是这样发生的，而且那就是，我不知道，这基本上就是我生活的方式。我喜欢那种方式。我只是想问，好吧，就像——我们可以聊遍你的无数作品，从《火线警探》（Justified）、《被解救的姜戈》（Django）、《牛仔和外星人》（Cowboys and Aliens）、《独角兽》（The Unicorn）等等你拍过的所有伟大作品，还有《盾牌》（The Shield），反正数不胜数。但仅因为这是最近发生的一件超级重磅的大事，那就是《白莲花度假村》（White Lotus），对吧？是的。我的意思是，你在那里面演得太特么棒了，那真是一个极棒的季，全世界都在看这部剧。它太火了。那感觉一定很不一样。
massive thing is White Lotus, right? Yeah. It's like, you were so fucking great in that, and it was such a great season, and the world watches that show. It's so massive. That must have been different.
而且你还能和你的好哥们萨姆·洛克（Sam Rock）一起合作。哦，我们的好朋友，萨姆·罗克韦尔。对，我喜欢萨姆。那一定很有趣。但在泰国拍摄肯定很，嗯，也许对你来说不是这样。你可能很喜欢那些闷热、流汗的天气，对吧？
And you got to work with your buddy Sam Rock. Well, our pal, Sammy Rock. Yeah, I love Sam. That must have been fun. But shooting in Thailand must have been, well, maybe not for you. You probably loved all the fucking hot, hot, sweaty conditions, right?
有很多露趾鞋。是的，就像。你会自己准备戏服吗？我18年前去过世界的那个地方。说来话长。我已经说过很多次了，所以我就不在这里重复了。但我去过整个东南亚。
Lots of open-toed shoes. Yeah, just like. I would just like, You provided your own wardrobe? I went to that part of the world 18 years ago. It's a long story. I've said it, so I won't repeat it here. But I went all over Southeast Asia.
一旦我到了人生中的某个阶段，在经历了一番钻研之后——我在20多岁时其实并不怎么去派对。你知道的，我高度专注于我要求自己去完成的事情。我不去，我的意思是，我去过，你知道的，
Once I got to a certain point in my life, after studying, like, I didn't party really in my 20s. You know, I was hyper-focused on what it was I was asking myself to do. I didn't go to, I mean, I went to, you know, I went to. Rocksbury. Wall of Brown Derby, right? or the, yeah, yeah, you know, all the places over in Los Felis with Elaine and, what's the name of the place? Yeah, anyway, I did all of that, but barely. And so then when I turned 30 years old and, you know, we were on the second year of the shield or after the first year of the shield, I just said, you know what, this is my time.
罗克斯伯里（Roxbury）。布朗德比餐厅（Brown Derby），对吧？或者，对，对，你知道的，洛斯费利斯（Los Feliz）所有那些地方，还有伊莱恩，还有，那个地方叫什么来着？是的，不管怎样，我都经历过那些，但只是浅尝辄止。所以当我30岁的时候，你知道的，我们正在拍《盾牌》的第二年，或者在《盾牌》第一年之后，我只是说：“你知道吗，这是属于我的时刻。”
Now, I'm just going to finish a job and I'm going to take off and go somewhere in the world and just hang out and get to know that place. And I've done that now, you know, a Sam's family and with family for, God, I mean, I'm 54 years old. So I've been doing that for 24 years. Your passport must be a mess. But it just gives you such a richness of life that's not just about doing this stuff. It gives you real world experience. Sean and I talk about this all the time. Like having that kind of real world experience and getting out in the world is important, man.
现在，我只是完成一份工作，然后我会出发去世界上的某个地方，四处闲逛，去了解那个地方。我以前也这样做过，你知道的，山姆一家和家人一起，天哪，我的意思是，我已经54岁了。所以我已经这样做了24年。你的护照一定一团糟。但这确实给了你一种极其丰富的生活，它不仅仅是关于做这些事。它给你真正的世界经验。肖恩和我经常谈论这个。就像拥有那种真实的阅历，去外面的世界看看是很重要的，伙计。
How do you do that? How do you find something new? to bring back to the table. I try to do that too. I think, I think it's what Will just said, I have to force myself to get out of the house. So I have... I'll put on CNN International, you know,
你是怎么做到的？你是如何找到新东西的？带回到餐桌上来。我也在努力做到这一点。我想，我想这就是威尔刚刚说的，我必须强迫自己走出家门。所以我有……我会打开CNN国际频道，你知道的，
and I'll just see how it's all going. I like to go places, man. But even like the dumbest things, when Jason asked me to go to the Dodgers game, I was like, yeah. And by the way, never been like to a Dodgers game and like those seats. But just as far as an experience goes,
然后我就会看看进展如何。我喜欢去各地，伙计。但即使是最蠢的事情，当杰森叫我去看道奇队的比赛时，我心想，好吧。顺便说一句，我以前从来没去过道奇队的比赛，而且那些座位……但就体验而言，
it's like, wow, I have that. in my brain now. Yeah, and you didn't take the 101. You took sunset. Oh, that was new for you, too. Backroads. And it was an 18-inning game. Oh, my God.
就像是，哇，我现在脑子里有这个了。对，而且你没走101号公路。你走了日落大道。哦，这对你来说也是新的。乡间小路。而且那是一场18局的比赛。哦，天哪。
Take the five, man. It was great, though. Now, what about, to talk, before we let you go, tell us about Fallout. Tell us about, so you've made a friend of the three-hour makeup session.
走5号公路，伙计。不过真的很棒。现在，关于，在采访结束前，跟我们聊聊《辐射》。跟我们聊聊，所以你和三个小时的化妆环节交了朋友。
It's certainly worth it. My God, what an incredible job they do with you. Thanks, man. It's a big, you know what? We got to do this, you know, you get a call from Jonathan Nolan. You know, the first word out of your mouth is, yes, you know. Right, right.
这绝对是值得的。天哪，他们为你做的工作太不可思议了。谢谢你，伙计。这是一部大制作，你知道吗？我们必须得接，你知道的，当你接到乔纳森·诺兰的电话时。你知道，你嘴里蹦出的第一个词就是，是的，你知道。对，对。
Read the scripts afterwards. And one of the writers was, she wrote Tomb Raider, and she was a friend of mine, Geneva, DeWartreason, and Graham Wagner. I knew through some friends. I was just a fan of his, really. But it started, it was all on the page. I didn't know, like, how they would tell this story. Yeah. And it was a lot.
看完剧本之后。其中一位编剧是她写过《古墓丽影》，她是我的朋友，吉妮瓦·德沃特雷森，还有格雷厄姆·瓦格纳。我通过一些朋友认识了他。我其实只是他的粉丝。但这开始时，一切都在剧本上。我不知道，比如说，他们将如何讲述这个故事。是的。而且内容很多。
Like, day one was really intense, thinking, like, man, I'm too old for this shit. Like, I don't know how I can pull this off. It was in New York, and it was like 99 degrees with a heat index of like 106. And then we just kept, go ahead. No, just to say your makeup, like, it's like you don't have a nose. No. So how do they do? I do.
就像第一天真的很紧张，心想，天哪，我老得干不了这破事了。就像，我不知道我怎么能撑过去。当时在纽约，气温大概是99华氏度，体感温度大概是106华氏度。然后我们一直在，你接着说。不，只是说你的妆，就像你没有鼻子一样。没有。那他们是怎么做到的？我有的。
How do they get rid of your nose? You know, they, they, it's called CGI. Oh, okay. Oh, I didn't know. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I thought it was like, yeah, okay. Still there. Yeah, they do that like in the post.
他们是怎么把你的鼻子弄没的？你知道，他们，他们，这叫CGI特效。哦，好吧。哦，我不知道。对，对，对。我还以为是，好吧。还在那儿。对，他们在后期制作中会做特效。
So people see me when I do my nose. Actually, I just saw these screeners that they send out to everybody. And one scene, they didn't do the effects on yet for the crack. Oh, fuck, that's my nose. Now, do you have to act with like a tracking mark on the tip of your nose?
所以当我处理我的鼻子时人们会看到我。其实，我刚看到他们发给所有人的片花。在一个场景中，他们还没为裂痕做特效。哦，操，那是我的鼻子。现在，你演戏时鼻尖上必须带着追踪标记吗？
Yeah, it doesn't affect me because I can't see it. But yeah, everybody else. Is it like a little X or a dot or a green? It is five dots. are four, one, two, three, four, four dots. I'll send you a photo. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So we did it, man, and it came out,
对，这对我没有影响，因为我看不见。但是是的，对其他人有影响。它是一个小X还是一个点或者绿色的？它是五个点。是四个，一个，两个，三，四个，四个点。我会发给你一张照片。对，对，对。所以我们做到了，伙计，它出来了，
and it was really well received, and it became, you know, one of the biggest shows in the world. I mean, it truly is a global experience. I mean, this game, you know, resonates so deeply with so many people all over the world, and we got an opportunity to do it again and jump right back in there. I've been on a long run.
而且反响非常好，它成为了，你知道的，世界上最伟大的剧集之一。我的意思是，它确实是一次全球性的体验。我的意思是，这款游戏，你知道，在世界各地的许多人心中引起了如此深刻的共鸣，我们有机会再次做到这一点并直接重新投入其中。我经历了一段很长的历程。
the best pilots I've ever since the first episodes I've seen it's it's amazing thanks man did you shoot the second season back in new york too no no no we're in l.a now man we're here yeah and and it feels it feels it feels good to be back here and to work with an la crew you know to see all of these so rare to work here yeah it's so tough here in this town right now but it feels great to look out and go yeah we're back home and so we did it we did season two and look look we've all been down these roads a number of times. And you know that if you get this first season, if you can get a critical mass to like it,
这是我自看到第一集以来见过的最好的飞行员剧集，太棒了，谢谢伙计，你们第二季也是在纽约拍的吗？不，不，我们现在在洛杉矶，伙计，我们在这里，是的，而且感觉，感觉，回到这里并与洛杉矶的工作人员合作感觉真好，你知道，看到所有这些在这里工作太罕见了好吧，现在在这个小镇上太难了，但放眼望去说，是的，我们回家了，感觉棒极了，所以我们做到了，我们拍了第二季，看，看，我们所有人都经历过这些事情好多次了。你知道，如果你拿下这第一季，如果你能获得批判性的大多数人的喜爱，
and I knew it with a shield and would justify it and with like the righteous gemstones or any of these things, that you have an opportunity to do something transcendent, really. I mean, if you can play it safe, or you can go for it. And that's what, you know, everybody did.
我通过《盾牌》知道了这一点，并通过《正义宝石》或任何这些东西证明了这一点，你有一个机会做一些真正超越常规的事情。我的意思是，如果你可以稳妥行事，或者你可以全力以赴。这就是，你知道的，每个人都做的事情。
And we're, you know, it's about, it's coming out on December 17th. That's right. On Amazon. Yeah, man. And we're really, really, really excited about it. Well, you always go for it. You always go for it.
而且我们，你知道的，关于这个，它将在12月17日上映。没错。在亚马逊上。是的，伙计。我们真的，真的，真的很兴奋。好吧，你总是全力以赴。你总是全力以赴。
And as I said at the top, you never drop us. You take us with you. You carry us safely on these great creative journeys that you take us on. What was the show that you and Danny did that killed me that was the other one before? Vice principals. I know Vice principals. Dude. Dude.
正如我在开场时所说，你从不让我们失望。你带着我们一起。你把我们安全地带上你带我们去的最伟大的创意之旅。你和丹尼拍的哪部剧把我迷得神魂颠倒，那是之前的另一部？副校长。我知道副校长。老兄。老兄。
You killed me in that, dude. Thanks, brother. Yeah. I would, I'd give a limb to work with you one day, buddy. So my fingers are crossed for that. Same. Same. This will have to do until then.
你在那里面把我演绝了，老兄。谢谢你，兄弟。是的。我愿意，我愿意用一条胳膊换取有一天能和您合作的机会，伙计。所以我为此祈祷。一样。一样。在那之前，这个就先凑合一下吧。
Thank you so much for coming on the show and talking to us. Well, and you're just a legend, dude. You are, buddy. I'll buy you a glass of whatever you want, whatever I see you next. And I look forward to. Just take me on a horseback ride. You know, I got to get cultured. Yes, anything.
非常感谢你来参加节目并跟我们聊天。好吧，你简直是个传奇，老兄。你真的是，兄弟。无论何时我再见到你，我都请你喝一杯你想要的任何饮品。我非常期待。带我去骑马吧。你知道的，我得提高下文化素养。好的，什么都行。
What if I, what if I knocked you? What if you woke up with me and my, in a tent in Mongolia. I would need a few batteries. It'd have to be a lot of batteries in there. Okay, man. All right, y'all. Thank you so much, everybody. Dude, thank you, thanks so, nice to see you. Great to see you, dude. All right, I'll see you soon. Bye, bud. Okay. Yeah, I love the slam. He slammed it. He did it. I love him. Yeah, well, I feel a little, I do feel a little seasoned, just even talking to
如果我，如果我敲门呢？如果你醒来时发现我和你在一起，在蒙古的一个帐篷里。我会需要几块电池。那里必须有很多电池。好吧，伙计。好了，各位。非常感谢大家，老兄，谢谢，很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你，老兄。好的，回头见。再见，伙计。好吧。是的，我喜欢这个重击。他猛地关上了。他做到了。我爱他。是的，好吧，我感觉有点，我确实感觉有点经验丰富，仅仅是和
him. I don't need to go to Mongolia just yet. I know. By the way, those are the kind of guys, like obviously we have tons and tons of favorite episodes this is one of my favorite ones like that guy i can talk to forever that he's how great is his vibe yeah it's great he's just his lust for life is just incredible and infectious wouldn't you want to invite him over it's funny he talks about walking him in a room every time he walks in a room he lights it up and it's genuine it's not put on that's so funny to hear him say that as i said i saw him the other night he just comes in and he just has this like joie de vivre as we've got sparkle oh a little fairy does he does have spark Yeah.
他交谈。我暂时还不需要去蒙古。我知道。顺便说一句，这类人，就像显然我们有无数最喜欢的剧集，这是我最喜欢的剧集之一，像那家伙我可以永远和他聊下去，他的氛围有多棒啊，是的，太棒了，他只是对生活的热情简直不可思议且极具感染力，你难道不想邀请他过来吗？有趣的是，他谈到他走进一个房间时，他每次走进一个房间都能点亮全场，而且这是真诚的，不是装出来的。听到他这么说真有趣，正如我所说，我前几天晚上看到他，他走进来就带着这种生命力，正如我们所说的小火花，哦，一个小精灵，他确实有火花。是的。
When you were talking about your experience, the outdoor thing, I wanted to tell my story about my camp when I went to camp. Oh, let's hear of it. As a kid, I went to music camp at Blue Lake Fine Arts Camp in Michigan. And it was in the middle of the woods. And that's my only kind of outdoor, long-term, woodsy kind of thing. Sure. Anyway, who cares?
当你在谈论你的经历，户外的事情时，我想讲讲我自己的故事，关于我去营地的那次经历。哦，让我们听听吧。小时候，我去过密歇根州蓝湖美术营的音乐营。那是在树林中央。那是我的那种唯一的户外、长期的、树林里的体验。当然。总之，谁在乎呢？
Yeah. But after two weeks of being in a camp in the middle of the woods, I was ready to say, Bye. Bye. Smartless. Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic
对。但在树林中央的营地呆了两周后，我准备说，再见。再见。Smartless。Smartless是100%有机且由罗布·阿尔姆贾夫、贝内特·巴尔比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里手工制作的。这一集还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可留下评论。
and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Dummy